Twitch, come on, brah.
Lass mich jetzt nicht hängen.
Nein, ich muss nicht warten, bis ich freigeschaltet werde.
Das ist immer instant oder gar nicht.
Alter Twitch, ich krieg Anfälle.
Was soll denn der Scheiß?
Lass mich in 1080p streamen.
Was soll das denn?
Leute, ich starte das jetzt so oft neu, bis ich 1080p darf.
Ich darf immer 1080p streamen.
Warum darf ich heute nicht 1080p streamen?
Was ist das?
Der Discord-Bot, der ist voll am abkacken jetzt.
Okay, wir...
Äh...
Maybe dangerous, MonkaS.
Ich das wirklich runterladen soll.
Hm.
Kann man sich irgendwo die Bitrate anzeigen lassen?
Videostats.
Bitrate, Playbackrate.
Guck mal, das fängt zu niedrig.
Zackt.
Normalerweise ist das instant da.
Ah, easy.
Jetzt geht's.
Okay, ich hab nix gesagt.
Hä?
Das dauert nie so lang.
Was ist das für ein...
Crap.
Naja, gut.
Ich will mich nicht beschweren.
Hauptsache es geht.
Easy.
As fuck.
So.
Das ist jetzt übrigens gerade der offizielle Stream, der hier läuft.
Aber wir installieren den Kram schon mal.
Wer weiß, was ich mir jetzt für 3 Milliarden Viren da einfange.
Also, guck mal erstmal, was ist denn das hier?
Erstmal einen .NET-Decompiler holen, gucken was da drin ist.
Ah, excellent, excellent.
Irgendwelches Binary-Geschiss.
Aha, aha, so, so.
Okay, ich glaub denen einfach mal, dass alles in Ordnung ist und dass man das jetzt ausführen kann.
Orpheus Ioannis Zephyrisis, das ist bestimmt ein Grieche, oder?
Das ist auch der, der gerade hier offiziell am Stream so an ist.
Run anyway.
Bam.
Virus ist raus.
So.
Venice Unleashed.
Oder, oder, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Wir brauchen, wir brauchen die korrekte Aussprache.
Die korrekte Aussprache ist...
Das ist ja eindeutig.
Ja.
Install.
Oh, vielleicht ein bisschen groß, die E-Mails gerade.
Setup Wizard aus 1995.
Excellent.
Finish.
Da ist er.
Oh, wow.
Startet einfach instant, lull.
Connecting zum Zeus.
Backend.
Okay, Moment, Moment.
Mein Benutzername.
Mein Benutzername ist...
Ich glaub MaxSource oder sowas.
Äh, Passwort.
Remember me.
Login.
Was?
Oh, es ist noch nicht, es ist noch nicht live, Leute.
Es ist noch nicht live.
Das Passwort ist richtig, Elevenhead, ja.
Okay, wir lassen es jetzt einfach auf.
Wir lassen es jetzt einfach auf.
Bis es losgeht.
Und, und, ich muss noch, ich muss, Bruder, ich muss mir noch eine Runde Musik anmachen.
Let's see.
Okay, hören wir mal an, was der, was hat er denn im offiziellen Stream zu sagen?
Is this the right screen?
Nope.
There we go.
Gleich geht's los.
Okay.
So.
This is not live yet, but I can actually hear.
Hold on, let me...
Pause champ.
Give me a second, give me a second.
I'll start putting things live, so you guys can actually start downloading again.
Du kriegst keine Sekunde.
Go, go, go.
We're gonna launch this together.
And hopefully everything goes to plan.
Because that's...
It's always fun.
So.
Gib alles.
Was das ändert, ja, das kann man nicht so genau sagen, weil es hat noch keiner gespielt, außer ein paar Modder.
Im Großen und Ganzen kann man sagen, es ist ein Modding Pack, also sprich, es gibt eigene Server, es gibt einiges an Mods, die bei Release da sind.
Okay.
Und es gibt Server bis 127 Spieler, bis, glaub, 120 Ticks.
Müssen wir mal gucken jetzt.
Ich hab selbst keine Ahnung, genau.
Es geht?
Ha!
Da ist es.
Guck mal, ich hab schon mal einen Soldier erstellt.
Okay, okay.
Also.
Create new Soldier.
New Soldier.
Cute.
Chat.
Also, wir haben zwei Varianten.
Entweder wir machen Cute Chat als Soldier, oder wir machen den alten Klassiker.
Warte mal, komm, wir machen den Klassiker, oder?
Wir machen den Klassiker.
Der Sex.
Okay.
Übelst fancy UI.
Oh.
Ha!
Excellent.
Okay, ich glaube, ich muss nochmal neu starten, alles klar.
Oh, was ist das?
Oh.
Pausierungschamp.
Da ist er.
Der Informatiker.
Kann man, kann man irgendwie.
Also, Servers.
Und, und was ist das?
Killstreaks.
Grand Bazaar Killstreaks.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Grand Bazaar Kongress mit Killstreaks.
Gib mir Rush, Alter.
Okay, Settings, Master, Value, und so.
Ich kann kein Kongress spielen, Alter.
Aber das ist jetzt egal, wir joinen da jetzt einfach mal.
noch a tdm ok wir spielen wir lieben spiel lieber grand bazaar
die leute macht die musik aus ich spiele lieber grand bazaar conquest bevor ich
noch a tdm spiele es geht auch ohne warum soll ich das dann machen
ok da übernimmt die alten klassen das schon mal nice
alter meint es war kein killstreak der mich gekillt hat vermutlich macht und
viel zu laut mein ort fliegt weg alter nein ich muss leiser machen leute ich
muss leiser machen lautstärke champ
audio ok ok ok ok post postgegner am stade einer hüpfungsdach dass ich was
sehe national der besten passion huge passion
beschloss aus rex so erstmal eine runde
zocken
killstreaks ok ok ich kämpfe jetzt mal ein bisschen das ein paar killstreaks
kriege camper tut mache ich jetzt hier kriegst medipack aller fliegt das weiter
als sonst killstreaks ok die große frage ist leute wenn irgendjemand checkt wie
man killstreeks press the killstreaks button in the spawn screen to select your
skills ich muss ich muss erst im spawn ich muss im spawn bildschirm killstreaks auswählen okay das habe ich natürlich nicht gemacht
naja das Adено hat sich hier schon vermieden
klaring
so ich hab jetzt eigene
ver 계ilian
ja ich falsche
vielen vielen
pläne
off geht's gehen oder ich dauer netz in lr wie easy isierin
er tiene clauson
Okay, also, ich soll hier angeblich
Killstreaks, ah.
Grenades,
Smoked, Adrenalin Rush.
Leute,
komm, wir machen die
High-Reward-Killstreaks. Oh, man kann
mehrere auswählen.
Grenades.
Achso, ich kann einfach alles auswählen. Okay, das ist
natürlich auch eine Variante, ja.
Ich glaube, das sind wahrscheinlich einfach nur Test-Killstreaks.
Es sind Scorestreaks.
Guck mal, es sind Scorestreaks.
Es sind gar keine richtigen Killstreaks.
T-Crate, wo sieht man das?
Weiß jemand,
wie man FPS-Overlay machen kann?
Das war irgendwas, Draw, FPS,
ähm.
Wow, äh, was war das?
Draw, Draw,
nee, FPS,
Render, Draw,
FPS 1, ne.
Ja, exquisite.
Excellent, excellent, excellent.
Äh, ich hab Squads Sprint, das
sagt, ich brauch Squad
Squad Cover.
Alter!
Was jetzt?
Okay.
Ah, yes.
F.
Ja, gut,
da kannst du nix machen, da kannst du nix machen.
Reconnect. Webseite ist
down, lul, weh.
Okay, was sagt der, was sagt der Dude im Stream?
Oh, oh, okay.
Das ist weg.
It's back, it's back, it's back, it's back.
Nein, don't panic.
Nein, ist nicht back.
Jet jubaded.
Massive jubade.
Dabei hätten wir jetzt gleich unseren ersten Killstrick gekriegt.
So, I think I'm set to auto-login right now.
But basically, the first time you launch
VU and you log in with your account,
uh,
it's gonna ask for the link to Origin account.
What that means is that you basically need to just
run Origin
while you have VU open.
And it's gonna do that.
Ich mein, ich mein, er ist zwar der Erfinder von
von, äh, wenn es anliegt, aber er muss mal
Aussprache, auch Sprache
üben. Wir wissen alle, dass es
heißt.
You can ignore it, I guess.
We have already submitted samples
to Defender and the rest.
So, it should be unblocked within a couple
of days, but if not, you can just add it
to your, uh,
to your list of exceptions for now.
Macht das jetzt...
Ah, nice, da sind wir wieder.
Da sind wir wieder.
So was.
Komm, wir sind die Ersten, die wieder eingeloggt sind.
Oh, der Server ist, glaube ich, weg.
Kann das sein?
Okay, da war ein offizieller Streamer wieder aus.
Ist der Killstreak-Server weg?
Ich will unbedingt den
Killstreak-Server, der war echt nice.
Äh, gibt's einen Refresh-Knopf?
Some serious
Honkers, alles klar.
Äh, kann das sein, dass das
erst refresht, wenn man da...
Ah, man muss da ein bisschen rumklicken, okay.
Ist wieder crashed.
Ist wieder down, ist wieder weg.
Ah, ne.
Okay.
Wo war denn der Killstreak-Server?
Sieht den irgendjemand?
Ach, hier.
Ah, ich glaube, die haben gerade ein wenig, ähm,
Stabilitätsprobleme, aber das bist du erwarten beim Release.
Das hätte mich echt gewundert, wenn das jetzt einfach so funktioniert.
Guck mal.
Paintschamp.
Ähm, from here you have a server browser,
which hopefully works.
Der nicht funktioniert, null.
Come on.
You can do it.
Ja, ganz ehrlich.
Sogar Blizzard hatte beim letzten WoW-Add-on wieder Probleme, ne?
Dann kann den ja wirklich keiner.
Okay, die Seite ist auch weg.
Einfach modded server.
Ja, und ein paar, und ein paar, äh,
Enhancements.
Wir haben, ähm,
120 Tick-Server oder sowas.
Oh, oh, geht's wieder.
Okay.
So, we got a server list.
So, these are all the servers.
That are currently live.
Uh, some of them are 120 Hertz,
some of them are 60 Hertz,
some of them are just 30 Hertz.
Soll ich jetzt reconnect-spammen bis es geht?
Man kann auch einen eigenen Server hausten, ja?
Weißt du, was verdächtig ist?
Niemand spielt.
Was im Endeffekt heißt, es kommt keiner gerade rein.
Dead game.
Guck mal, bei ihm geht's auch nicht mehr.
Monka ist, ach nee, ich bin da gar nicht eingeloggt.
Macht nix.
Wenn deine Credentials falsch sind, dann sind die, ah, wir sind wieder da.
We are back, Leute.
Das halte ich ja für ein Gerücht, dass das am Stabilizen ist.
Ist bestimmt, ist bestimmt ein C++-Backend.
Okay, okay, das ist total überlastet gerade.
Oder Java, oh Gott, hör mal auf.
Java-Backend.
Nee, ich glaube, es ist Lua.
Ich glaube, das ist alles Lua.
Ist irgendwo mal aufgeschnappt.
Oh!
Es macht was.
Mach mal aus und wieder an.
Ich das hier lieber auf der Webseite, oder irgendetwas so.
Bitte geh auf die Website.
Da ist die Hilfe in der Report-Sendungen.
Und geht auf...
Wennesunleashed.net und lädst runter.
Das Problem ist nur gerade, dass die Webseite kaputt ist.
Guck mal hier, Entwicklerbonus.
Der kommt rein.
Ich neig.
Sauerei.
Oh! Login, Login.
Pauschamp.
Pausierungschamp.
Es tut sich was.
Champ.
Pauschamp.
Aaron Jesus!
Komm, komm!
Das sind sozusagen private Server.
Ja, nur dass du halt viel mehr machen kannst.
Okay, das ist RIP.
Das ist RIP, Alter.
Ich meine, immerhin.
Wir haben immerhin schon mal...
Wir haben immerhin schon mal Grand Bazaar gespielt
bis zum ersten Killstreak, ja?
Nee, RIP. RIP, da tut's nix mehr.
Das ist vorbei.
Ist ja fast wie unter Windows.
Tja.
Ist der Sibaro da?
Der Sibaro hat sich doch so einen 64-Kerne-Ultra-Server gekauft.
Sponsor den mal da für die.
Ich glaube, die Server selbst sind gar nicht das Problem.
Die Spiele-Server nicht.
Die Gameserver für das Management,
die Backend-Server für das Management
sind wahrscheinlich das Problem.
Das sind Kills, das sind Scorestreaks.
Scorestreaks.
Scorestreaks wie ein Kot, ja.
Also, was ich jetzt gesehen habe, ist,
es gibt Granaten als Scorestreaks,
es gibt einen Artillery-Strike als Scorestreak,
irgendein Adrenalin-Rush,
was wahrscheinlich sowas wie ein Heal
und schneller Schießen ist oder sowas.
Ja.
Genau, die hätten das mal alle mit Blockchain machen sollen,
dann wäre das nicht passiert.
Genau.
Ja.
Ach, die sind Single-Fan, die Server.
Ja, dann.
Äh,
äh, du brauchst, glaub, du musst,
du brauchst kein Lizenz-Key,
du musst, das steht in der FAQ bei denen auf der Seite,
guck mal, also ich würde ja die Seite aufmachen,
äh, das steht irgendwo in der,
irgendwo in der, in der FAQ drin, ne?
Was war, Docs?
Ähm,
da steht drin, dass du mit deinem Origin-Account
dich verknüpfen musst,
aber das hatte ich wohl schon mal gemacht.
Okay, RIP, Leute, da tut sich grad nix.
Starten wir nochmal neu.
Okay, wisst ihr was?
Ich, ich, ich erlaub dem, ich erlaub dem Firewall-Typ jetzt.
Exes.
Wurscht.
Dann ging's doch vorher auch, aber.
Ja, Captain Peng, das haben grad alle.
Die sind ein wenig überlastet.
Ich mein, du kriegst wenigstens ne Fehlermeldung,
bei mir ist es einfach, bei mir ist es einfach unknown.
Ha!
Tut sich wieder was.
Aber wenn du im Chat guckst,
bei dem offiziellen Stream, die spammen alle rum,
äh, ist in Use from another Location.
Okay, come on.
Gib alles.
Okay, Leute,
das erinnert mich fast ein bisschen an ein Blizzard-Release.
Gut, nee, aber ohne Scheiß,
wirklich kein Geflame an die, an die, an die Jungs, ja.
Die konnten das wahrscheinlich vor allem mit so vielen Leuten gar nicht ausprobieren.
Probieren sich wahrscheinlich grad irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
5000 Leute zu connecten.
Jetzt häng ich im Loading-Screen.
Top.
Da war ich schon mal.
Du bist jetzt im Server-Browser.
Oh, Poggers.
Dann machen wir das einfach nochmal.
Airworker, wie lang musstest du warten in diesem Loading-Screen?
Ich mein, wir haben's ja eben gesehen, es ging übel schnell, ne?
Zehn Sekunden, okay.
Du hast dasselbe Wort, bester.
Bester Wallpaper.
Woher bekomme ich den Mod?
Du gehst hier hin,
in thisunleashed.net
und dann download.
So, if you're getting
Client in Use from another Location, you can try restarting the VU client.
But I'm not sure, if it's gonna work entirely.
In the meantime, I'm trying to fix it.
In some of the other issues as well.
And we will see.
How it goes.
Wir sind im Server-Browser.
Give me a few minutes.
Trying to see what we can do here.
Oh, okay.
Ja gut, da müssen wir mal kurz warten.
Okay.
Wir müssen die Hackermans hackern lassen erstmal.
Warum ist das eigentlich, warum ist das eigentlich kein Dark-Theme?
Kann man auf Dark-Theme umschalten, wenn man nicht eingeloggt ist?
Ja, kann man.
If you're getting a black loading screen, then that means that something probably went wrong
and you're gonna have to restart your,
your client.
Macht ihr nix draus mit Account erstellen?
Ähm, wir können ja auch grad nicht spielen.
Egal, egal.
Ne, ich spiel jetzt keine normale Runde.
Ich will jetzt das spielen oder nix.
Wo kannst du deinen Origin-Account verbinden?
Das Problem ist, ich kann's hier nicht genau sagen,
weil ich hab das wohl schon mal gemacht.
2016, weil mein Origin-Account war schon verbunden.
Aber du kannst dir's hier in der FAQ-Seite angucken.
Da steht's, guck.
Du musst, genau.
So, du launchst den Client und dann sagst du
create account, bla bla bla.
Ähm.
After you create your account
and logged in to the
Venice Unleashed Client.
So, und dann musst du das Ganze irgendwie, frag mich nicht,
wie das geht.
Ich hab das wohl schon vor Uhrzeiten mal gemacht.
Vielleicht macht er's auch automatisch, wenn's läuft.
Oh, oh.
Ja, wir sind mal wieder da, Leute.
Mal wieder, jetzt mal wieder.
Können wir wieder einloggen.
Und, und?
Server?
Come on, please.
Plus RNG.
Ach nee, gibt's ja nicht mehr.
Ah, er macht das automatisch, okay.
Ja.
Okay, hören wir mal, was der, was der im Stream sagt.
Ich werd jetzt einfach, wisst ihr ja, dass das ein Problem ist?
Also, das, das ist ein Problem, das hatten wir auf der Arbeit auch schon.
Wenn ein Service down geht, will man ja eigentlich,
dass nicht auf einen Schlag 50 Millionen Benutzer wieder drauf,
okay, das ist übertrieben.
Okay, please.
5000, sagen wir mal, 5000 Benutzer, ja?
Bei uns auf der Arbeit sind's ungefähr 40.000 Benutzer, so.
Und, ähm, du willst ja eigentlich nicht, wenn der Service down ist,
wegen Überlastung, dass, ähm, dann instant wieder 40.000,
okay, RIP,
wieder instant 40.000 Leute draufkommen.
Und das Problem ist, dass alle Leute es so machen wie ich,
wenn der Service down ist.
Reconnect, reconnect, reconnect, reconnect.
Und alles, was das macht, ist,
im Prinzip noch mehr Last erzeugen auf nem Service,
der eh schon down ist, weil er zu viel Last hat.
Aber, obwohl ich das weiß,
ich kann mich nicht davon bremsen,
ich kann mich nicht bremsen, das auch zu machen.
Hat jemand einen guten Server?
Ja, der Sebarro hat so ein 30-Milliarden-Core-Ding.
Ha, Servers.
Postchamp.
Ach, come on.
Es ging doch am Anfang so schön, ey.
Wir waren drin, haben unseren ersten Killstreak gemacht,
und dann,
Edu, war dann angesagt, ja.
Erzähl mal, wie war's bis jetzt?
Ich hab fünf Minuten gespielt,
hab nen Killstreak gemacht, den ich nicht auswählen,
nicht einlösen konnte, weil's gecrashed ist.
So, perfekt.
Äh, ist das ein DLC, oder ist das jetzt ein komplett neues Game?
Das ist eher so ne Art DLC, also nicht wirklich.
Es ist ne Modifikation am Basisspiel.
Also, du brauchst das...
Du brauchst das Game original?
Jetzt muss ich jetzt mein Passwort wieder tippen.
Okay, okay.
Mein Passwort, ja.
Okay, RIP. RIP.
Jetzt vorbei.
Jetzt hab ich auch diesen komischen Fehler.
Client neu starten, okay.
Wir starten den Client neu.
Also, wie gesagt, ich mach den da gar nicht.
Ich find's super, dass es das gibt.
Ich beschwere mich nicht.
PP Hands.
Frost Champ.
Was können die Betreiber denn so machen,
wenn die Server so hart überlastet sind?
Es kommt drauf an.
An was es liegt.
Wenn's nicht am Server selbst liegt,
sondern vielleicht zu irgendeiner Connection sonstwohin,
fragt mich nicht.
Dann könnte man das ein bisschen upgraden, was auch immer.
Ja?
Vielleicht machen sie irgendwelche Cloud-Geschichten
und müssen einfach ein größeres Paket nehmen.
Ähm...
Vielleicht können sie irgendwelche Optionen tweaken.
Was auch immer, ja.
Könnt ihr...
Oh, oh Leute, wir können uns einloggen.
Oh nee, es gibt nur noch keine Server.
Ja.
Okay, es bleibt uns nichts anderes übrig.
Zu warten.
Aber ist nicht schlimm.
Ist nicht schlimm.
Was, 400 Mann sind drin?
Wo sieht man das?
Okay, ähm...
We're gonna try a couple of things.
Hat er das grad gezeigt im Stream?
Ach, hat ein Offhead gesagt.
Okay, nice.
Wie gesagt, ich kann auch noch warten.
Ist ja nicht wild.
Niemand hätte erwartet, dass ein Cloud...
Guck mal, sogar Blizzard kackt ab.
Ich mach hier mal wieder aus,
weil sich das sonst wieder rumspackt.
Mit use another location.
Gibt's eigentlich mal ein Update zum Schneestelz über die Baustelle?
Ja gut, die Baustelle ist keine Baustelle mehr.
Ich wohne seit sieben Jahren in dem Haus.
Again, if you're getting errors, just hold tight.
Servers are currently experiencing a lot of load.
Oh, wir howlen sowas von tight.
Das glaubt der gar nicht.
You can hear my nervous knee wiggle.
Das glaub ich eben.
RTX voice is calling me once again.
Ich hör kein Kniegedingse von ihm.
Servers?
To be honest, I didn't expect this many of you.
You come and join.
Also das ist...
Eins hab ich mittlerweile gelernt nach zehn Jahren IT-mäßig.
Du musst immer mit dem Schlimmsten rechnen bei sowas.
Es gibt keine Server.
Alles weg.
Also die Server sind mit Sicherheit noch da,
aber der Master-Server oder wie auch immer die das machen,
wird nicht funktionieren.
Du musst immer mit dem Schlimmsten rechnen und mehr.
Es hat mir mal jemand in der Ausbildung gesagt,
damals, also schon ewig her,
wenn mich einer...
Und es hat sich im Nachhinein aber rausgestellt,
der hat Recht.
Er hat gemeint, wenn dich einer fragt,
wie lange es dauert,
dann nimm den schlimmsten Fall an
und das mal 2,5.
Und das trifft es bei vielem.
Also sprich, wenn die sich überlegt haben,
ach, wenn es hoch kommt, spielen das 1000 Leute,
dann sollten sie lieber mit 2500 rechnen.
Ultimative Dice Experience.
Ja, ist wie bei Battlefield 4 Release.
Ist ähnlich, ja.
Die Musik im Hintergrund, ja.
Ach, die ist bei ihm.
Der hat komplett Recht, der Typ, ne?
Der hat komplett Recht.
Also dieses, was ich jetzt auch mache,
dieses permanente Reloaden,
habe ich euch ja gerade erzählt,
ist an sich schlecht.
Vielleicht sollten wir uns mal, ähm...
Sollten wir uns einfach mal einen neuen Soldier erstellen.
Ist dem das eigentlich unangenehm?
Bestimmt.
Wenn du einen Launch-Livestream machst
und dann ist die hellste Slife, geht es nicht.
Natürlich ist einem das unangenehm.
Lieber noch eine Runde...
Wie gesagt, ich spiele nicht normal jetzt.
Oder vielleicht...
Vielleicht doch.
Ach, Create Sold...
Oh!
Was jetzt?
Ah.
Top!
Wir könnten ja die Diablo Immortal spielen,
in der Zwischenzeit.
Die hätten die Queue einbauen müssen.
Das wäre Big Brain gewesen.
Immortal ist, glaube ich, Beta gerade oder sowas.
Pulse Champ und dann immer Pippehands, genau.
So sieht es aus.
Erst Pulse Champ und dann 10 Sekunden später...
Oh, lul, weh.
Ah, ich bin ja nicht eingeloggt.
Oh, lul.
Weh.
400 Zuschauer, ja?
Alle warten so auf Battlefield 3.
Und ich kann nicht spielen.
Aber ich bin ja beruhigt.
Der offizielle Release-Stream kann auch nicht spielen.
Loading Simulator.
Ich sage ja, wie bei einem Blizzard-Release.
Könnte man sowas im Voraus testen?
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass sie das gemacht haben,
aber einfach nicht mit so vielen Leuten gerechnet haben
und deshalb das nicht getestet haben.
Was?
POG ist wieder klein im Chat?
Ja, der Chat buggt.
Der Chat buggt.
Okay.
Jetzt kommt wieder...
Jetzt kommt wieder Pippehands gleich.
EA DDoS bestimmt.
Ich sehe die Hackermans.
Ich sehe die Hackermans in Stockholm schon sitzen gerade.
Die Hackermans in Stockholm.
Es kann nicht sein, dass die hier beliebter sind als unser Original-Spiel.
Erst mal alles DDoS'en.
Chinesisches, indisches Botnetz.
Auf geht's.
Stimmt, der DDoS von DICE funktioniert nicht.
Zu schlechter Netcode.
Zu schlechter Netcode für DDoS.
Glaubst du, das wird heute?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Und selbst was ich glaube, ist vollkommen egal.
Ich kann es nicht beeinflussen.
Aber es sind nur viele Leute,
die gleichzeitig verbunden sind.
Und es ist nicht sehr...
Es ist nicht sehr gut für die kleinen Server.
Leider.
Kleine Server.
Ja, dann müssen wir denen doch mal ein bisschen...
ein bisschen...
Server sponsoren.
Dein Server ist gecrashed.
Geht die Webseite noch?
Okay, die Webseite geht noch.
Ich meine, Leute, wir können uns glücklich schätzen.
Wir waren einer der ersten in-game
und wir haben immerhin zwei Minuten spielen können.
Ja?
Ja.
Ich gucke jetzt einfach nicht hin.
Ich gucke einfach nicht hin.
Ich warte jetzt einfach,
bis die Serverliste geloadet ist.
Und...
Ich kann mir den...
Ich kann mir den Pepehands-Moment nicht angucken.
Oh.
Und wieder weggucken.
Ja, ich habe auch ein paar Kills gemacht.
Bis ich den ersten Killstreak bekommen habe.
Und dann war...
Crash.
Cat Jam Chat.
Wenn mal so viele Leute da sind.
Zu der Musik kann man eigentlich nur Cat Jam.
Und geil ist es.
Naja.
Wir haben zwei Minuten gespielt.
Schwer zu sagen.
Gibt es Custom-Maps?
Ja.
Potenziell schon.
Die haben sogar einen Map-Editor.
Wollen wir mal in den offiziellen Discord joinen
und gucken, was da so abgeht?
Jetzt machen wir jetzt mal.
Ähm...
Ja, da sind wir doch.
Da sind wir doch auf dem...
Discord.
Tja, äh...
Wo geht man da hin?
General?
Release?
Wo...
Wo gibt es...
Oh.
Guck mal, der Captain Peng ist auch da.
Alter.
Wie viele Leute sind da am Start?
Let's go.
1.887 Leute online.
Das ist ganz schön viel.
Guck mal, wie viele sind denn bei mir?
Hier sind es gerade.
Und...
äähh...
275.
Ja.
Guck mal.
Oder 100...
Die könnten auch 1, 3, 3, 7 online haben.
Spampen wir nicht rum, sonst wird ich noch gebannt.
Justin ICU hat die Leute zum Spammen aufgerufen oder so.
Bam.
Jetzt.
Kick, Alter.
Feedback.
Massive Game.
Oh, da ist jetzt einer ganz furchtbar lustig.
Was?
Ja, gut, da ist jetzt...
Die wissen es ja auch nicht.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass die gerade wild am Basteln sind im Hintergrund, dass es irgendwie tut.
Close.
Ja, next.
Oh, was jetzt?
Wahrscheinlich einfach Timeout.
Hören wir nochmal, was der offizielle Stream sagt.
Pass auf, den trollen wir jetzt.
Sorry, wenn ich nicht zu einigen deiner Botschaften antworten kann.
Ich versuche einfach, das zu lösen.
Also wenn man das beendet und macht neu auf, dann connectet er neu und man kommt manchmal direkt in den Server-Browser.
Problem ist nur, was? Wer ist in?
Wieso hat dein Stream eigentlich den Tag-Ingenieurswesen?
Weil wir hier Big-Brain-Sachen machen.
Der Stream hat angefangen. Ich versuche einfach, das zu lösen. Das ist das Einzige, was ich jetzt habe.
Was ist das für ein Stream?
Ich versuche einfach, das zu lösen. Das ist das Einzige, was ich jetzt habe.
Also nicht für das Spiel an sich, sondern für NPCs und Menüs und hast du nicht gesehen.
Das ist was relativ Klassisches.
Die haben irgendwo eine fette Datenbank stehen, denke ich mal.
Ich denke mal, dass Webseite und Game, beziehungsweise Webseite und dieser Client auf eine ähnliche Datenbank zugreifen.
Weil die Webseite und Accounts müssen verbunden sein.
Dann vermute ich mal, dass sie eine eigene Kiste für die Webseite haben.
Und irgendwie so eine Art Master-Server für den Server-Browser.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Lua ist nur für die Mods. Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe den Source-Code nie gesehen.
Aber nachdem die Mods in Lua sind, ist die Chance, dass der Server selbst in Lua ist, auch ziemlich hoch.
Und dass der Client in Lua ist, glaube ich nicht.
Wir können mal gucken, ob wir rauskriegen.
Oh, oh. Oh ne, jetzt hängen wir wieder in Loading.
Ist ja wie bei Wolzen-Release.
Alter, Wolzen.
Ich weiß bis heute nicht, wie man Wolzen ausspricht.
Der Client ist nicht .NET.
Ich wollte nämlich gerade mal probieren, ob man mit dem .NET-Decompiler irgendwie rankann.
Wie, er kann spielen?
Ach ne, das ist der Trailer.
Das ist der Trailer.
Null weh.
Dezember 2020.
Korrekt.
Der Client benutzt Chromium Embedded für die UI.
Ja, wundert mich nicht.
Wer mag schon gerne UIs selber malen?
Das ist einfach Trailer, der läuft, lull.
Wie kann man sein Origin-Account verlinken?
Angeblich macht er das automatisch, wenn du beides offen hast.
Äh, NoSplitHero neu starten.
Aber es kann aktuell keiner spielen.
Ich mache einfach ein Drittel der Battlefield-3-Viewer.
Ja, der Witz ist ja, es ist ja nicht mal wirklich Battlefield 3.
Ich, äh, Battlefield 3, äh, Loading-Simulator mache ich gerade.
Äh, NoSplitHero, da musst du wahrscheinlich einfach warten, weil es geht bei keinem Grad richtig.
Man kann Suppression deaktivieren.
Man kann den Blau-Filter rausmachen.
Komm, ich probier's jetzt mal mit dem anderen Soldier.
Sil-Pause-Champing.
Ja, ich Pause-champe innerlich schon nicht mehr.
Ich Pee-Po fette gerade eher.
Als, weil es nicht funktioniert.
Der Typ ist geil.
Oh!
Die haben, die haben den besten, die haben, die haben das beste Keg-Emote am Start.
So ein guter Server, guter Server.
Fletcher, danke schön für den Sub.
Übrigens, Leute, falls ich irgendwas übersehen hab, heute, an Subs, danke an alle, alle, die gesubbt haben, ähm,
ich war gerade zu beschäftigt mit auf, äh, Reconnect klicken.
... oder something like that, that adds progression.
Pause-Champ, Pause-Champ.
Ah!
Wie ist's, wenn dies unleashed so?
Ja, wenn man spielen kann, nice.
Wir konnten ganze drei Minuten oder so spielen, dann ist alles gecrashed und seitdem geht nix mehr.
NicoCS, dankeschön für elf Monate Subscription.
Du bist eins vor HyperSub hier.
Die Musik erinnert mich an einen Geek-Generator.
Ja, kommt nicht von ungefähr, das ist halt 8-Bit-Gedudel, aber eines meiner absolut Lieblings-Soundtracks hier.
Hoffentlich machen die Devs auch irgendwie wa...
Ja, klar, mach diese...
Was meinst du denn?
Die sitzen nicht einfach da und drehen Däumchen.
Wenn man sowas launcht, will man, dass der Kram funktioniert.
Die werden im Hintergrund massig am Basteln sein gerade.
Gibt's da überhaupt Content? Es gibt schon einiges.
Eben waren wir zum Beispiel auf dem Killstreak-Server.
Die sind richtig am Hackerman machen gerade alle.
Ja, es ist Fake-8-Bit-Musik. Es ist 8-Bit-Musik mit modernen Tools.
Auf dem Discord kann man den Stream anschauen, wie er am fixen ist.
Oh!
Da gucken wir jetzt mal.
Discord-Stream, wie er am fixen ist.
Wie?
Wie guckt man sich Discord-Streams an, Leute?
Wie geht das?
13 Dankeschön, 7 Monate.
Ich hab noch nie nen Discord-Stream mir angeguckt.
Du musst in den Channel.
Ja, welcher?
Leak Releases?
Nee, hm.
Ach, in den da muss ich rein?
Dann muss ich erst mal mein Mikrofon ausmachen, sonst laber ich die hier voll.
Und, äh, die Ausgabe auch, sonst schreien die Leute hier rum.
Ähm...
Und jetzt?
Ah!
Warum spielt der?
Will er uns streambaiten?
Ah ja.
Okay, gucken wir uns den Hackerman-Stream an.
Ich starte mal in der Zwischenzeit wieder.
Oh, man muss das gar nicht Fullscreen machen.
Was sehen wir denn hier da?
Fix me, fix me, fix me sehe ich da.
Excellent.
Fix me.
Das erinnert mich an Ryan.
Oh, Tmax, bester.
Da weiß man, das ist schon echt der Hackerman, wenn er Tmax am Start hat.
Ach, das ist ein VU-Server.
Wenn sowas, ja.
Okay, hier gibt es nichts zu sehen.
Hier raus.
Aha, der Informatiker ist wieder am Start.
Oh, Discord aus, da gibt es nichts zu sehen im Discord.
Unter Linux mit Wine, ja, das habe ich schon gelesen.
Das habe ich gelesen.
Ja.
Ja, ja, ich habe das gestern schon gesehen.
Irgendeiner hat es mir auf Twitter geschrieben.
Oder hat mir einen Link geschickt und da stand dann, es läuft unter Wine.
Filters.
Tja, gut, äh, ja, äh.
Was soll ich machen, ne?
Da zeigt er den Trailer.
Okay.
Er hört sich ein bisschen, er hört sich ja schon ein bisschen gestresst an, muss man sagen.
Übrigens, Leute, nice, dass so viele am Start sind.
Aber wir können gerade nicht spielen, weil jetzt gerade alles gecrashed ist.
Wo kommt ihr eigentlich alle her?
War so eine Frage.
Kommt ihr über YouTube her?
Seid ihr immer schon mal öfters auf Twitch am Start hier?
Oder habt ihr das gerade über irgendwelche Umwege über Twitch gefunden?
Zufällig.
Du bist wegen der Silvana, ja, verstehe, verstehe.
Ja, Leute, ich fürchte, das wird nichts mit Spielen.
Können wir einen neuen Soldier createn?
Cute Chat.
Ob es dann irgendwie geht?
Okay, Cute Chat können wir schon mal erstellen.
Stammgast seit 10 Jahren, das ist exzellent.
Nee, das Server-Browser funktioniert nicht.
Ja, gut.
Also, Leute, wir werden das so machen. Guck mal, ich bin jetzt fast eine Stunde on.
Und ich bin sehr, sehr entschuldigt, weil ich gleich auf euch starten werde.
Morgen, KS.
Jetzt startet der Server neu.
Und wir werden einer der ersten sein, der restartet. Ich sag's euch, Leute.
Ich bin sehr, sehr entschuldigt.
Wir machen jetzt zu und sobald der auf den Knopf drückt, starten wir das Ding.
Also, ich, sagen wir mal so, ich bin jetzt fast eine Stunde on.
Eine halbe Stunde bleibe ich noch da, sollte es nicht funktionieren.
Weil, ich sag mal so, also, ne, ne, zwei Stunden auf Refresh drücken müssen wir jetzt nicht.
Okay, let's see if this does anything at all.
Hat der jetzt schon gestartet?
Viewer-Rekord.
Nee, nee, kein Viewer-Rekord.
Viewer-Rekord war mal bei irgendeinem Apple-Livestream.
Da hatte ich irgendwie 750 oder sowas.
Jetzt probieren's alle.
Bei irgendeinem Apple-Livestream hatte ich mal 750 oder sowas.
Und da haben sich die Leute beschwert, dass ich, als ich mich drüber lustig gemacht hab, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was das war.
Was hab ich mich lustig gemacht?
Über irgendeinen Trailer von Apple hab ich mich lustig gemacht.
Da waren die Apple-Fanboys am Start und haben im Chat quasi, äh, wo hab ich das passende Emote quasi sinnbildlich sowas gesagt.
Piss dich, Aldo!
Da haben sie sich voll beschwert, das weiß ich noch.
Wo wir dann beim Thema sind, man sollte nicht zu viel fanboyen, hat man nix von.
Also das einfachste, was die machen könnten, wäre...
Aber das werden sie nicht machen.
Einfach alle blocken.
Irgendwo bei ihrem Anbieter.
Und einfach nur spezielle Leute reinlassen.
Aber!
Das wollen wir ja nicht, weil es soll ja ein Public-Release heute sein.
Okay, Leute, wir kommen noch nicht mal mehr rein.
Eben sind wir immerhin bis zur Soldier-Selection gekommen.
Aber jetzt kommen wir noch nicht mal rein.
Äh, du kannst denen sicherlich was donaten.
Ja, ja, ich glaub...
Der Community-Fund...
Gibt's da noch...
Ja.
Kannste hier...
Musst mal gucken.
Also wenn das gut funktioniert, und wenn ich da ein paar...
Werde ich ihnen auf jeden Fall auch was donaten.
Tyson, please fix Servers!
Es ist aber schon hart am echten Release dran, ja.
Wie kann man sein Origin verknüpfen?
Angeblich macht er das automatisch, wenn man Origin und das gleichzeitig startet.
Also gleichzeitig anhat.
Das mit den Donations ist übrigens auch so eine fragliche Sache, weil es könnte sein,
je nachdem wie die Benutzerbedingungen oder was auch immer es gibt, was von EA da gilt,
sobald man was verdient, in irgendeiner Art und Weise, kommen die vielleicht um die Ecke
und wollen es dicht machen.
Es ist immer echt schwierig, auch für Free Shards in MMOs Donations zu nehmen.
Max, kannst du uns erklären, warum das Projekt notwendig ist?
Die Battlefield 3...
Oh!
Das ist doch online!
Weil du damit viel mehr machen kannst, als mit den offiziellen Battlefield-Servern.
Erstens ist Battlefield 3 offiziell relativ tot mittlerweile.
Und es gibt halt null Chance auf neuen Content.
Und hiermit gibt es Map-Editor.
Du kannst eigene Mods machen, wie zum Beispiel Killstreaks.
Du kannst 120 Tick-Server hosten, bis zu 127 Spielern.
Sind diese Server auch bei Konsolen oder nur PC?
Nur PC.
PCMR.
Nee, das geht jetzt wieder nicht.
Ja, drin waren wir auch schon öfters.
Aber wir hatten in der Serverliste nichts drauf.
Eingeloggt waren wir auch schon oft.
Aber man kommt nicht in die Serverliste.
Ja, der Jadji baitet wieder.
Bin drauf, bin drauf.
Serverliste voll.
Lululul.
Oh, okay.
Das ist...
Ist es endlich soweit?
Ja.
Aber es geht nicht.
Weil alles gecrashed ist.
Debate, Chat.
Debate.
Fünf Server online.
Nice.
Chat, ich bin auch drin.
Auf dem zweiten Monitor.
Und ihr seht es bloß nicht.
Ich habe 20 Leute in der Serverliste.
Also...
Du hast es.
Irgendwie?
Etwas?
Er klingt ja mittlerweile echt ein wenig verzweifelt, was ich aber auch verstehen konnte.
Oh oh.
Er hört sich echt verzweifelt an.
Was ist in den Weep-Ordner auf dem Desktop?
Habe ich da einen Weep-Ordner?
Ah, Jadji bait.
Lul.
Massive Jadji bait.
So, wir kommen irgendwo hin.
Wir kommen irgendwo hin.
Wir kommen nahe.
Ist das so?
Wir kommen sehr nahe.
Oh, oh.
Wow.
So, es...
Es...
Es funktioniert ein wenig.
Und dann gibt es etwas, das es...
Äh.
Paper Hands, Alter.
Refresh.
Excellent.
Operation Metro conquest.
Randomizer rush-Server.
Da gehen wir jetzt drauf.
Was?
Hab ich veräppelt?
Nein!
Okay.
ProMod!
Der RSMGG funktioniert.
Okay.
Nein, es ist wieder kaputt.
Es ist wieder RIP.
okay leute ich gebe ich also eine halbe stunde noch mehr mehr mehr loading simulator marx net
also man sieht ja dass kaum einer spielen kann gerade was hat es mit dem 60 herzen 120 herz
auf sich das ist wie oft das server zu dem server klein sich updaten also wie oft das
server updates verschickt pepe hans kann ich mal joinen sollte man jetzt sein können der
metro server der hier
ist vielleicht mal eine firewall irgendwie jetzt die rumspackt oder so
weiß kann ja nicht sein eben konnten wir auch noch spielen man ist einfach die windows firewall aus
da kann ja nichts mehr passieren wie macht man das überhaupt
wollen sie
und
wir
We can look into that
daran liegt schon mal wieder nicht
problem is even if i added one
the ui for it won't be there
oh
es lädt ok ich glaub trotzdem nicht dass es an meiner
firewall lag
it's loading
aber wir sind alleine auf dem
server der viertel fabian ist auch
da was sind wir
denn überhaupt attacker
was sind ah ah wir sind attacker ok
der lustmolch
ist da jawoll
lustmolch
excellent
we made it
seems to be a different issue
ist das ein hardcore server
leute ist das hardcore
was jetzt
restart
ist das ein hardcore server
oh please
nein
kein hardcore server
nein crash
oh
es ist ja ein unding
haha der friseur ist am starten
nice max wann starten wir den
260 jim
ja wenn corona vorbei ist
klar oder
dann gibts hier max
boss transformation stream bei fabian
auf dem channel
operation fire pro mod
meme factory
fabian jetzt wo du da bist
und
und der chat ist ja auch da
chat chat
ihr müsst dem fabian jetzt mal alles sagen
dass wir zu weihnachten ein video zusammen aufnehmen müssen
da würde sich der chat
sicherlich drüber freuen oder
oh es geht nicht
wood face
oh disconnected
please
lass mich einfach spielen
ich will unreal tournament
spielen
ich will nicht dass es lädt
weil wenn es lädt dann
stützt es ab
nee ich weiß gar nicht
wie ging das nochmal
ich will nicht dass es lädt
oh das ist
graphic language
keine ahnung wie man das nennt
das darf man heute nicht mal sagen
auf twitch
ich will nicht dass es lädt
ich weiß nicht mehr was er erzählt hat
weil wenn es lädt dann stützt es ab
der typ ne
hercules beats oder so
das ist der typ heute
übelst der alpha man
ok
operation firestorm
all dlc maps
operation metro large
wenn es lädt dann dauert es immer so lange
das kann auch sein
ah please
so wisst ihr was
bei dem ist es ja im endeffekt satire
wenn du es so willst
der hat ja alle gebetet
die fernsehsender damals drauf reingefallen sind
aber wisst ihr was
heute sitzen die zwölfjährigen fortnite leute
wirklich so vorm rechner
der hat es predicted
also leute noch
25 minuten
wenn es in 25 minuten nicht geht
gehe ich auf
klär mich mal auf
was ist jetzt an dem
das ist ein mod
zum basis spiel
also sprich du kannst custom server machen
du kannst sachen entfernen aus dem spiel
zum beispiel diesen blaufilter
und du kannst bessere server erstellen
also theoretisch wenn es denn läuft
du kannst custom mods wie killstreaks machen
das erste
also die erste runde die wir spielen konnten heute war
ähm
grand bazaar mit killstreaks
und den ersten killstreaks haben wir erreicht
und dann ist gecrasht
ja aktuell kann man nix
ja das stimmt
aber fabian wenn ich dich richtig verstanden hab
das liegt bestimmt daran
das die einfach nicht
das richtige mindset haben
ne
du brauchst das richtige mindset
hast du eigentlich mal
den neuen warzone modus gespielt
nein hab ich noch nicht
du bist top 1
in der battlefield 3 kategorie
das ist ja auch nicht schwer
in der battlefield 3 streamt ja auch keiner
du brauchst den lizenz key nicht
lizenz key ist glaub ich für server erstellen
du musst
ähm
einfach nur origin
und wenn es unleashed gleichzeitig starten
dann geht das
aber aktuell geht ja grad gar nix
oh massive gift
hier von xfetal
hat dem friseur was geschenkt
big brain
ich steh für den sub
und für das gift
jetzt kanns wieder gehen genau
ja wie siehts aus
nehmen wir zu weihnachten was auf
wir brauchen nur irgendein gescheites thema
oder wir schwätzen einfach ne halbe stunde sinnloses zeugs
setzen uns in discord
und sagen da master chief blblblblbl
oder irgendwie so n scheiß
und das laden wir dann hoch
aber das können wir glaub ich 2020 nicht mehr bringen
da sagen die leute alter was ist mit euch los
ihr seid halt 36 und sitzt im discord
und labert so n scheiß
und dann kommt der master grabber an
und der soll auch ins discord kommen
und der karsten
nein sowas wie discord verwende ich nicht
und dann wird das nix
das haarschneide special
ja gut wir brauchen ja auch noch das
ähm black ops 1 facepaint video
25 12 dusch
genau wir machen battlefield 3
dual stealth machen wir
ich glaub der fabian hat damals auch kein battlefield 3
richtig gespielt ne
oder wir haben bad company 2 gespielt
aber battlefield 3 haben wir auch nicht gespielt
haben wir glaub ich nie nie wirklich gespielt
das war nicht so deins
weil its a schleiper
wann ich aufstelzen will
ja wenn du willst
also ich hab urlaub bis
nächstes jahr und ich bin eigentlich eh immer da
weißt du doch
also wenn du willst
100 stunden battlefield 3 video
nein das war nicht vom friseur
das war der
der torsten meldet sich zurück war das
der das battlefield 3 100 stunden video gemacht hat
zu lange her
ewig her
ok
also wirklich was machen geht hier wirklich grad
gar nix
oh ist wieder mal komplett gecrashed
nice
er ist ein
ansauger 82
ist das der bruder von puster
das ist das gegenteil
wie siehts mit battlefield 6 aus
wie gehypt bist du
man weiß von dem game noch gar nix
wie kann ich da drauf gehypt sein
es gibt ja zu battlefield 6 nix
es gibt zu battlefield 6 nix
außer
dieses komische
video
wo da random soldaten rumrennen
was ist eigentlich diese anime stimme
die texte vorliest
das ist
das hab ich selbst gebastelt
da kannst du bilder overlayen
ich hab übrigens auch einen französischen poggers
und kannst audioclips abspielen
zum beispiel
oder aber auch
und und
ja
oder ganz wichtig
easy as fuck
ja wenns so easy wär
ja genau und
dahinter läuft irgendein koreanischer
text to speech service
nee auf den service kannst du nicht zugreifen
also ja kannst du das ist ja ne public service
ich weiß aber nicht mal wie der hieß
irgendwie
irgendwas koreanisches oder japanisches
text to speech
also war das ganz nice
ich mach das mal aus und wieder neu an
zumindest war das ganz nice
weil du konntest einstellen ob du sprecher
oder sprecherin haben wolltest
und wie so die emotionen
ich hab auf super begeistert
und erfreut irgendwie gestellt
deswegen hören die sich jetzt alle so ultra gehypt an
wenn die was vorlesen
easy as fuck
battlefield 5 dicke siehst du
hat leute
ja das ist was modernes wird
da geh ich ja auch mal von aus
ab dem
erst mal ab erster weltkrieg war
dann zweiter weltkrieg
und das jetzt wieder was modernes kommt
die leute schreien das ja auch schon seit jahren
das ist jetzt wie gesagt da muss man kein großer hellseher sein
dass das in battlefield 6 soweit sein wird
ich persönlich wär immer noch für nen
bad company 3
aber halt ordentliches bad company 3
im sinne von bad company 3
und eine eine idee
egal ob für battlefield oder call of duty
die ich seit jahren schon hab
wo ich mir echt hoffe dass das irgendein hersteller umsetzt
ist
weil beide serien gibts ja nun schon ziemlich lang
und ich glaub die idee wär für nen call of duty
sogar mehr geeignet
die sollen mal so nen
so nen
alternative realität
szenario machen
und was noch viel geiler wär
wenn es irgendwie so nen
also ich red jetzt von ner kampagne
ich red jetzt von ner kampagne
was ich richtig geil finden würde
nachdem die jetzt ja auch angefangen in black ops
also im letzten black ops haben die ja auch angefangen
die modern warfare welt
und die black ops welt
so ein bisschen miteinander zu verschmelzen
ja du hattest ja charaktere aus modern warfare
die jetzt in ner black ops kampagne drin waren
und sowas
und was die machen sollten ist
wenn ein neuer teil rauskommt
die sollten quasi das
welcher film war das denn
ich kann mich jetzt gar nicht dran erinnern
zumindest die sollten ne kampagne machen
wo du quasi
als keine ahnung
in jedes bisherige call of duty
wieder reinkommst
und dort irgendwas fixen musst
oder so
was auch immer die sich da für ne story drum herum ausdenken
also die könnten quasi so nen komplettes best of call of duty machen
mit ner coolen so
alternative realität szenario drum herum
aber ich glaub das ist zu abgedreht
das ist zu abgedreht auch dafür
aber ich fänds geil
du könntest ja zwischendurch nen script schreiben
der den reconnect button spammt
ja das könnte ich
ne das wär doch
ohne mist
das wär doch richtig geil
wenn du beispielsweise ne kampagne hättest
wo du dann dafür sorgen müsstest
dass sob nicht stirbt in mw3
oder dass
dass man so key momente aus allen call of duty kampagnen
quasi
als unabhängiger dritter
irgendwas ändern muss
sodass halt der zeitfluss wieder stimmt
irgendwas
die sollen sich mal irgendwas so inception mäßiges zusammenspinnen
oder so aber da könnte man
was ultra geiles sicherlich draus machen
aber das ist glaub ich zu abgedreht
für call of duty single player
oh spoiler für mw3
null ja stimmt
mw3 spoiler
stimmt ich hab quasi euch das übernächste modern warfare gespoilert
weil wir haben ja
die haben ja zwischenzeitlich einfach mal modern warfare resetet
wir waren ja schon bei 3
aber jetzt sind wir ja wieder bei 1
ok leude 13 minuten noch
wenns bis dahin nicht geht
gibts nen grund
was sagt der offizielle stream
der sagt gar nichts
der spielt einfach weiter trailer ab
ok
leude ich glaub es war keine so gute idee
direkt zu release das zu probieren
also
wenn ich eins gelernt hab
aus 13 jahre it
einfach mehr hardware draufschmeißen
hilft manchmal nicht
und das könnt ihr auch mal sehen
also
auch der fall sein
manchmal hilft mehr hardware draufschmeißen nicht
fahrstelle hin und hilft
ja weil ich auch so viel ahnung davon hab
was da eigentlich läuft
zu release klappt sowas nie
man könnte ja im prinzip sagen
es ist quasi die originale dice release experience
only in battlefield leute
ok der ist fertig mit den nerven
das battlefield ist das
genau
ja genau fabian die streamen auch
der typ hier
der der der
wo hab ich den jetzt
alter hier der
der hat aber nicht alleine den mod gemacht
ist aber wohl der gründer
oder so
weil sein name steht bei dem ganzen zeug dran
oh das geht halt nicht
ok vielen dank für den sub
excellent
ne ich glaub das können wir vergessen
wisst ihr was
ich warte jetzt noch 10 minuten
und wenns nicht geht dann geh ich off
und komm nachher wieder
weil das hat ja keinen sinn
da stimmt das mindset nicht
der müsste sich einfach mal dein letztes video angucken
und da hätte er wissen müssen
dass er einfach sein mindset fixen muss
und was in dem fall bedeutet
er hätte außer
wenn ihr es unleashed programmieren
einfach nichts anderes mal machen dürfen
er hätte einfach die letzten jahre
den ganzen tag nur hackerman machen müssen
dann wirds jetzt besser gelaufen
ist das mit dem richtigen mindset nicht auch das
was hier dings kann
ich hab ja schon ein video geguckt
ich hab schon verstanden wie du es meinst
ist was ganz was anderes
ja schon klar
aber das ist doch das
was so die ganzen scammer auch immer erzählen haben
wisst ihr was ich immer am besten finde
die typen die dir erzählen werden
ich bin jetzt 21
und bin
sinngemäß erzählen sie
dass sie reich sind
und ich habe raus bekommen
wie man mit coaching und consulting
richtig viel geld verdienen kann
ich habe dazu jetzt ein buch geschrieben
und ich zeige dir jetzt
wie du das auch kannst
alter
was ein dumm gelaber immer
vor allem nix vorzuweisen
irgendwelche 22 21 jährige
no name typen die da hocken
und die erzählen wollen
sie haben jetzt die lizenz zum geld drucken
irgendwie gefunden
gerade auch stumpfsinn
also wer da drauf rein fällt
dem ist echt nicht mehr zu helfen
aber das träumen halt viele leute von
ich mein wenn du mal so rumfragst
bei den leuten von was träumst du
ganz viele leute werden sagen alter ich will reich sein
dementsprechend fällt das
da auch auf näherbaren boden
weil die sagen hey
wir zeigen dir jetzt
wie jeder volldepp ohne jegliche
qualifikation und gehirn reich werden kann
angeblich
so und da denkt natürlich
oh geil wenn der das kann dann kann ich das auch
das einzige was die machen ist
den typ reich
vielleicht aber nicht sich selbst
das buch für 50 euro kannst du nicht verkaufen
das kauft keiner
du musst das buch kostenlos rausgeben
und dann den leuten irgendwelche seminare
bei dir buchen lassen und sowas
kannst du mal nen link zum venice unleashed stream schicken
ja hier da guck da
orpheus
die basics genau
kennst du schon den kls song
ne gibts sachen die muss ich mir nicht angucken
ich kenn auch nicht
der hat ja krasser witze neues song
der fabian kennt den bestimmt
der ist bei sowas immer informiert
aber ich ignoriere youtube deutschland zum grössten teil
der desktop
der ist top
besseren desktop wirst du nirgendswo finden
bester desktop eu
ok ok geben wir nochmal das passwort ein
login server dauern
ja anscheinend
das ist immer noch der trailer
oh
wir sind mal wieder drin
aber wir sind wieder da
aber wir kommen wahrscheinlich nicht auf den server drauf
nope
qchat mal gucken ob qchat geht
wie ist der stand der dinge es geht nix
wir konnten insgesamt 5 minuten spielen
am anfang mal 2 minuten und zwischenzeitlich wieder 2 minuten
keine chance
ja ich guck mal morgen
ich mein
wir könnten noch eine runde
normales battlefield 3 spielen
wie rush
komm wir spielen noch ne runde normales battlefield
eine runde
eine runde geht
komm wir spielen eine runde normales battlefield noch
eure
alter ernsthaft fabian wirklich
du hast dir das gekauft
nee oder
oh ist hier der spawn raven
oh oh oh oh
kommt her
pausierungs champ
au
ok ok
ah von links
so viel
oh nice tx
achtung wallbang nade
zack zack
jetzt kommen sie bestimmt von der mitte
sind sie auf der anderen seite sind sie alle abgehauen
guckt sie euch mal an ey
blyat blyat blyat
ok pass auf
big brain flank
what
ok da stimmt was nicht
hack muss hack sein
immer hack ihr wisst wie das ist
und wenn man verliert hack
nein es geht nicht
ich spiel ne runde normales battlefield
weil ich keinen bock hab
jetzt eineinhalb stunden umsonst da gesessen zu haben
das game ist ein bisschen leise oder
ticken lauter können wir das gleich noch machen
alles hacker im gegnerteam
muss muss
muss
wenn du verlierst ist prinzipiell hack
der typ gammelt da vorne rum
wir müssen hier rein leut
lets go lets go lets go
diffuse champ diffuse champ
auf auf auf
nice
massive diffuse
so und jetzt gehen wir hier vor und bashen sie wenn sie lang kommen
jawoll next please
auf komm um die ecke
wallbang nade sehr gut
bam bam bam
hinter s
so wo sind die nächsten
oh da geh ich net raus da kann ich net raus
wenn ich da raus geh bin ich down
so
alter jetzt kriegen sie auf den sack ich sags euch leute
die retzen den bestimmt
monka monka
monka what the fuck
oh shit
ok ich mach mal n ticken lauter kurz
bis ich was hört
nein venice unleashed
ist im im im arsch rip
geht grad nicht
jetzt sind wir alle verreckt
oh ich hab sprint
ich brauch kein sprint ich brauch cover
ne wir haben cover cover haben wir schon
nope
aber die nade die nade ist gut rein die nade ist gut rein
was kein kill mit der nade
ne venice unleashed
geht grad nicht ich spiel jetzt auch nur die runde
hier
ich spiel jetzt auch nur die runde
hier und dann geh ich auf
ich will euch nicht jibayen mit venice unleashed
und und äh
und dann ist es gar nicht venice unleashed
jibaydet
wir probieren es danach
nochmal wenn die runde fertig ist locken wir uns nochmal ein
ach ist ja venice
venice ist es ja
was hab ich eigentlich immer mit so venice
so heißt es korrekt
also wer denkt er weiß wie man es ausspricht
die korrekte aussprache ist ehrlich gesagt
venice unleashed
ich hoffe ihr merkt euch das jetzt alles
einzig wahre aussprache
hey bay dankeschön für den sub
venice unleashed
so wo kommen die denn jetzt
bleib doch on his way ne
ne ich geh jetzt lieber was futtern
und
äh guck ob es nachher funktioniert
ist nice dass so viele da sind
extremer
pock
sag mal wenn ich suppressed bin das mein recoil nicht
das mein ähm
ironsight nicht richtig runter geht
ist das der berüchtigte nvidia
recoil bug in battlefield oder ist das einfach
wegen der suppression
atom poggers
massive huge poggers
voll in den kopf alter lul
ups haha ist ja meiner
die stellsten
alle voll von dahinten hin
neet
nein dann lass mich in die
aaaaaaaah
in the ass
hanemick shooted
guck mal 19-4
wer carryt hier grade
wie ist venice das ist nicht venice das ist vanilla
oder ist nicht venice das ist vanilla
weil venice läuft nicht
venice ist kaputt
broken as fuck grade
glaubt mir ich würd
auch lieber venice an die spielen
oh den typ stelzen wir uns jetzt
lass weg
nein
der mod ist online ja aber es läuft nicht
es läuft nicht mehr
kohlkopf nicht sterben
fuck
aber es läuft nicht es ist gecrashed
du brauchst
keine dlcs es sei du willst dlcs
spielen wenn du dlcs spielen
willst
wenn du dlcs spielen willst brauchst du dlcs
aber du brauchst nicht einfach
so dlcs
depends man
ok
ich versuch mal da durchzukommen jetzt
irgendwie schaffen wir hier über die gas
wonka s
wonka straße
wie gesagt wir kommen ja wieder fast vor wie in cs
wie man hier an der ecke
an der ecke stelzen muss
die mcom ist weg
ne ne ne ne
kollege so nicht
kommen die jetzt von hier oder wo sind die denn
fuck
ok vielleicht krieg ich
oh die kommen jetzt hier die wollen hier rum stelzen
hopp nein
ah wo sind denn alle
battlefield 3 für 1 euro ja du musst mal bei
irgendwelchen keyshops gucken
du musst mal bei irgendwelchen keyshops gucken
du kriegst das garantiert billig
safe
oh wir haben kein squad
suppression deswegen geht das nicht
muss ich gleich mal switchen
ohne so oh oh oh
depends man ist am start
ohne suppression geht nix
lets go lets go lets go
oh jetzt machen wir was
jetzt kommt huge flank
massive flank kommt jetzt
flank of doom
ok war schon mal nix
wo sind denn die
alle
wo sind
sind die schon durch
lol weh
hallo
die sind schon
die sind schon durch
ok
alter was soll ich machen
ja danach gucken wir nochmal wie
wenn dies unleashed
oder wenn es unleashed funktioniert
wahrscheinlich wirds nix
also jetzt brauchen wir erstmal squad cover
ja ach ja stimmt
ey wo wir gerade dabei sind
wenn ihr amazon prime habt
dann gibt es gerade battlefield 3 kostenlos
bis ende dezember
und das ganze könnt ihr bis januar einlösen
ok
ja alles auf niedrig halten das spiel ist alt also dass das funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut
okay easy easy los nein das ist bei mir auch da und deswegen habe ich gerade eine runde auf
offiziellen server gespielt ok mama zu und guck mal ob es wieder funktioniert venedig entfesselt
ja ich auch ich auch errichtet gerade login limit ein und dann sollten wir uns aber mal ganz schnell
einloggen ganz viel reconnects beim ati oder du bist ja auch mal wieder am start ist eine
tiu tiu behalte das mal lieber und spielt selbst eine runde ach so aber danke für das angebot so
ja gut was war jetzt leute denkst du das game kann battlefield 3 wieder bleiben wenn er aktuell aber
im prinzip ja
ich hoffe zumindest ich hoffe zumindest ich hoffe zumindest ich meine ich rechne nicht damit dass
das jetzt 500.000 spieler hat oder sowas aber sag mal so wenn wenn abends zehn server voll sind wäre
ich voll und ganz zufrieden also wenn es ordentlich läuft manchen eigenen server da mache ich ein
127 player metro grand bazaar
crossing killstreak server metro explosive only genau also ohne ohne mist werde ich nicht machen
schön und gut dass es 127 spieler gibt aber das spiel ist nicht ausgelegt für 127 spieler also
wenn ich mir einen eigenen server mache und wenn das gut funktioniert und gut läuft gehe ich mal
von aus dann mache ich den 32 mal rush server 32 mal rush server only only only gute rush maps
dem brenn Ariana
Also, da kommt dann rhein kann paul gar sangro singotti San Italienronr Fragen
你看 touch
tieren highway
DLC maps weiß ich dich würde ich würde auch gern dlc maps machen aber
ja
weiß ich ob das sinnvolles
was ist wenn es gute neue gem faithful 195
Ein nervi
könnte je nachdem was es für killstreaks gibt ja also was bescheuert ist ist so ein ding wie
eine nuke oder so das ergibt keinen sinn aber zum beispiel wenn du nicht killstreaks wohlgemerkt
scorestreaks scorestreaks weil wenn du in metro beispielsweise übelst gebasht wirst und es wäre
cool wenn man das einstellen kann zum beispiel ac 130 killstreak nur für attacker wenn es nicht
vorwärts geht irgendwie so da könnte man richtig schön balancen das ganze denkt euch mal die spawn
rape in metro du machst aber trotzdem 20 kill ac130 haust alles weg und kommst noch zur nächsten
base wärs schon nice ja na sana wir haben gerade mal eine runde live metro gespielt er hat gesagt
er hat etwas dummes gemacht was vielleicht hilft wir auf drei maps ich muss noch mal eine übersicht
mit dem battle for 3 maps also was sind gute maps gibt es da sind alle
Okay, sind doch einige.
Log ein. Ja, ich probiere es ja die ganze Zeit.
Was meinst du denn? Meinst du, ich sitze dann
eineinhalb Stunden hier und drehe Däumchen oder was?
Also, zeig mal her.
Was willst du denn beim Metro für Streaks
für Verteidiger nehmen?
Also, bei der ersten Base, je nachdem,
wenn es ausgeglichen ist, gar nichts.
Nachtmodus.
Oh ja,
sieht ziemlich unterschiedlich aus.
Alle Hackermans am Drücken, ja.
Also, ohne Scheiß,
ein LLV oder sowas auf dem Metro,
wäre schon cool. Gab es in der Alpha?
Alter,
er muss sich wirklich nicht entschuldigen.
Ich meine, die haben fünf Jahre lang
harte Hackermans gemacht
und jetzt läuft es halt nicht so.
Ist wie bei den Großen,
wie bei den Großen.
Guckt euch das an.
Schaut euch den letzten Vault of Warcraft Lounge an.
Der hat auch nicht funktioniert.
Er ist ein bisschen gestresst.
Es gibt zumindest
ein paar tausend Versuche,
die ich gerade gesehen habe.
Naja, das haben jetzt alle das gemacht,
was ich auch gemacht habe.
Genau, mir fehlt nur das richtige Mindset.
Stimmt.
Nicht pro Sekunde, aber
in den wenigen Sekunden,
in denen ich
dieses Rennen hatte.
Wir versuchen es wieder.
Ach, Maxinger,
der Entwickler von dem Killstreak-Mod.
Nice.
Okay, okay.
Oh, exzellent.
Oh, wir hatten Glück.
Wir hatten richtig Glück.
Okay.
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch
mit Servern.
Also, wenn ihr keine Servern seht,
dann,
was könnt ihr tun?
Easy.
Auf geht's, Leute.
Auf geht's.
Operation Firestorm.
Map, die ich überhaupt nicht mag, aber egal.
Hauptsache, wir kommen rein.
Da sind wir.
Rush. Sehr gut.
Sehr gut, Leute. Sehr gut.
Volle Pulle.
Pencilman ist am Start.
Ich hätte Engie nehmen sollen, aber gut.
Nein. Nein.
Defender? Auch okay.
Alter, ich bin am Arsch der Welt gespottet.
Ich muss zum Panzer, ich muss zum Panzer, ich muss zum Panzer.
Ich muss zum Panzer.
Jetzt bin ich Engie gespawnt und hab kein Panzer, ey.
Okay, dann, dann nehme ich wenigstens mit, Alter.
Nee, da hinten ist noch einer.
Da ist noch einer.
Ah, huge, huge tank, huge tank.
Erst mal LKW bashen.
Leute, ist der Blau-Filter jetzt weg?
Oh, er hat gesagt, oh oh, das ist schlecht.
Oh no.
Wenn der Entwickler oh oh sagt, ist schlecht.
I think
that thing is bad.
Five per second is too much.
What is happening?
Okay, we're gonna, we're gonna lower it to one per second.
Da ist gerade übrigens einer durch hier.
One per second.
I can see that.
Oh boy.
Pencilman.
Kommst du raus?
Yeah.
That's what it's gonna be.
Uff.
Hallo?
Please?
Sterben?
I'm gonna try a couple more.
Wo ist hier was?
Nein!
Nein, PepeHands!
Nicht wieder!
Nicht schon wieder!
Oh fuck.
Es geht gerade los.
F.
Um.
Oh, what is this from?
Oh.
Okay, yeah.
We'll do this one per second.
And.
Hey!
Sie sind wieder da!
Weeee...
Yeah, we'll see how it goes.
Probably not very well.
I think the server crashed.
Ah almost, crashed.
Eh, QDL, das geht gleich wieder weg.
No, UPnP is currently disabled.
Es gab ein Update!
Du sollst neu starten.
You've got to made it!
You got to made it! You've got to made it! You got to made it! You've got to made it! You've got to made it!
Die Starte garantiert nicht neu, wenn nur einer pro Sekunde reinkommt.
Oder einer gleichzeitig reinkommt.
Ha!
Okay, Firestorm.
Nosha Candles TDM 35 vom...
Okay, Firestorm Rush. Da waren wir doch eben auch schon drauf.
Gibt es da einen Stream, wie du den Server aufsetzt?
Ich werde erstmal aufs Stream gucken.
Nosha TDM gibt es mehr.
License Key kannst du ignorieren. Ist erstmal egal.
Ich glaube, License Key ist wahrscheinlich für Server erstellbar.
Also, du musst nur dein Origin offen haben.
Origin.
Und wenn es anliegt, musst du aufhaben.
Grip.
Oh!
Oh, okay, Leute.
Ich glaube, das wird heute nichts mehr.
Nicht schon wieder.
Der Song ist dafür gemacht, in der Schleife zu laufen.
Kann man hier Loop einstellen?
Geht das?
Mittlerweile irgendwie Advanced Autoplane.
Bester Song.
Der läuft im Spiel auch die ganze Zeit in der Schleife.
Echt?
Ah, exzellent.
Oder, oder was wir auch machen können ist...
Moment, Moment.
Was auch gut für solche Wartesachen ist, ist...
10 Stunden.
Ey, einer pro Sekunde.
Du musst einfach nur...
Einfach nur lang genug klicken.
Keine Server.
Okay, ist egal.
Wer braucht schon einen Server?
Ja, Tio geht mir ähnlich.
Ich hab das auch total oft laufen.
Einfach so.
Eigener Server.
Mach ich, aber bestimmt nicht heute, wo nichts funktioniert.
Also, die Sache ist die, wenn man fetten Single-Core...
Angeblich braucht man fetten Single-Core.
Das heißt, das hier ist schon mal nicht das Beste.
Also, wir brauchen...
Fetten Single-Core.
Sowas hier bräuchte man da.
29 Euro im Monat.
Alliance Apps.io ist das der offizielle Host.
Also, ich hab nämlich gelesen, dass er irgendwie gepartnert ist mit euch oder so.
Rent Venice Unleashed-Server.
Ich bleib bei Venice.
Ich weiß, dass es Venice heißt, aber irgendwie hat sich Venice bei mir so eingebrannt.
Oder Venice Unleashed-o.
Performance.
120 Hertz, 48 Spieler.
Ja, genau das.
Das brauchen wir.
32 Mann Rush.
120 Hertz.
Exzellent.
So machen wir das.
Oh, High Performance.
Jetzt dreht er langsam durch.
Das dreht mit Sicherheit...
Oh.
Das darf man nicht machen.
Lull.
Haben sie schon vorgebeugt.
Wenn man sowas macht, wird man automatisch rausgeworfen.
Oh, da sind wir wieder.
Oh.
Die Bananenspielwiese.
Norsha TDM.
Bam.
Excellent.
Was Besseres kann uns jetzt nicht passieren als Norsha TDM.
Fullscreen, please.
Norsha TDM.
Was jetzt?
Wie hast du so viel Glück?
Ich hab einen schnellen Spawnfinger.
Norsha TDM.
Gibt's...
Instant voll.
Der Server, habt ihr's gesehen?
Instant.
Norsha.
Ich sag übrigens, Norsha TDM.
Norsha TDM.
Ich hab den Flow überhaupt nicht mehr drinnen, ja.
Düt.
Oh, wow, wow, wow.
Soldier rules.
Oh, ich bin mit Q-Chat drinnen.
Q-Tot-Chat.
Q-Tot-Chat-to.
Auf.
Bäh.
Ist da immer schon so ein komisches Ding?
Alter, Suppression, please.
Das ist nicht mal der Typ, der mich gekillt hat.
Der M16-Mensch.
Aber es läuft.
Wenigstens.
Suppression in Grease-Mode.
Okay.
Konnte man nicht hier irgendwie so krass einen Stelzer-Man auf dem Dach machen?
So einen massive Stelzer-Man auf dem Dach?
Wow.
Clear.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ha.
Wo geht hier was ab?
Wo ist hier was?
Ich seh hier nix.
Nicht mein Kill.
Ah.
Alter, 13-4, gell?
2-2.
Easy.
Ich bin null drin in TDM.
Ach, stimmt.
Da kann ja beim Team jetzt spawnen.
Alter.
Jetzt ist hier...
Ach so, das ist...
Moment, wie viel Spiel...
Das ist hundert...
Jetzt check ich's erst.
Das ist 103 Leute.
Noscher TDM.
Alter, deswegen ist das so krank.
103 Leute.
Jetzt versteh ich's auch erst, warum das grad so abgefuckt ist.
Noscher TDM, Alter.
Kein Wunder.
Kein Wunder, dass hier nix geht, äh.
Haha.
Lol.
Ey, guckst du dir an, äh.
103 Metro, ey.
103 Metro wäre mir fast lieb.
Ich geh da wieder raus, ey.
103 Noscher, das kannst du ja nicht spielen.
Ich mein, guck dir das mal an.
The fuck?
Alter, 103 Noscher.
Guck mal, 20-7 schon.
Ey, 103 Noscher ist zu krass.
Das ist zu hart.
What the hell?
Was ist hier los?
Nee, nee, nee, das ist 103.
103 Leute sind das.
Ich kann doch nicht rum weiter runterscrollen.
Guck mal, die Runde ist schon vorbei.
Nach zwei Sekunden.
Oh.
Das ist Shipment.
Das ist quasi Shipment.
Dazu fällt mir nur eins ein.
Hä?
16-16?
Ernsthaft?
Da stand doch 103 eben.
Da stand eben 103.
Ja, 103.
Da waren wir eben.
Nee, das stimmt nicht, die Anzeige.
Okay, was haben wir denn sonst noch zu bieten?
Operation Metro Conquest.
Rush gibt's nicht.
Conquest Domination.
Metro Conquest.
Excellent.
Ja, aber Damawand Rush gab's nicht.
Conquest Metro.
Gibt's schon 200.
Man, nee, 200, man, geht nicht.
Maximal 127.
Komm, von der Seite gleich noch welche.
Was war denn das gerade?
Was hat gerade der da gemacht?
Das hat übelst gelaggt.
Habt ihr's gesehen?
Das hat übelst geruckelt beim Schießen.
Vielleicht liegt das an 120 Hertz.
Da kommt's game nicht mit klar.
Ja, guckt mal.
What the fuck?
Fünf-Hertz-Server.
Der PC ist gerade einfach gestorben bei dem Typ.
Der Server ist einfach RIP.
Nee, nee, ich kann teilweise...
Alter, ich kann teilweise nicht mal rennen.
Ich kann nicht mal rennen teilweise.
Okay, das ist RIP.
Das ist vorbei.
Ey, nee, pfff.
Okay, okay, okay.
Gucken, ob's noch was anderes gibt.
Please nicht ausloggen, please nicht ausloggen.
Okay, okay, was haben wir sonst noch?
Metro.
Metro Conquest Lodge.
Okay.
Meinung bis jetzt.
Ich hab noch keine einzige Runde fertig gespielt.
Maxinger, gibt's den Killstreak?
Gibt's den Killstreak-Server?
Das ist eigentlich der, wo ich...
Ich war am Anfang auf dem Killstreak-Server drauf.
Und als ich den ersten Granaten-Killstreak erreicht hab,
war...
Oh, nee.
Was jetzt?
Oh, oh.
Oh, oh, Leute.
Okay, schauen wir mal den Windows Defender wieder an.
An dem lag's ja offensichtlich nicht.
Was, DC?
Oh, die Big-Brain-Chat, Leute, wieder am Start hier.
Nice.
Okay, was machen wir denn jetzt?
Operation Metro Conquest Lodge.
War das nicht der Grade, wo wir uns dahin
connecten wollten?
Dammit, Peak Rush.
Okay, okay.
Mit der Taste neben 1 machst du das auf.
Dammit, Peak Rush.
Okay, mach irgendwas Gescheites jetzt.
Okay, Kirby, Ruhe.
Affe mit Waffe, alles klar.
Wie macht man eigentlich jetzt noch mal den Blau-Filter aus?
Wie ging das denn?
Wie macht man den Blau-Filter aus?
Ich weiß, dass das theoretisch geht.
Oder ist das Server-Setting?
Das ist bestimmt Server-Setting, hä?
Wie der Server einfach instant voll ist.
Server-Side.
Aber wo konnte man Damavent Peak noch mal hoch?
Irgendwie hier, ne?
Cool.
Quit fucking around.
So sieht's aus.
Aber 103 Leute Damavent Peak, Alter.
Das ist ja schon wieder Monarch-Es.
Jetzt werde ich gestream-schneid wahrscheinlich.
Achtung, Yolo-Man.
Auf, lauf, Alter.
MonkaS.
Alter, 103 Spieler.
103 Spieler.
Ich werd verrückt.
Das kannst du dir kaum spielen, Alter.
103 Metro, äh, 103 Damavent Peak, please, äh.
Ich weiß nicht, angeblich sind's 100...
Nee, es sind 16.
Sind 16.
Da steht ja standarderweise von 103.
Der Heli-Mann.
Es sind ganz schön viele drauf, ja.
Es ist voll, würd ich sagen, oder?
Also angeblich 103, aber es kommt mir nicht vor wie 103.
Vielleicht steht da einfach nur 103 da.
Der Rest ist im Loading-Screen.
Ja, aber guck mal, bei uns, das sind nur 16, ne?
Es sterben auch ganz schön viel grade.
Max mit dem zweiten Account, lol.
Laut Server-Browser 65 mit max 103 Slots.
Vielleicht ist einfach die Ingame-Anzeige auch nicht ganz Herr der Lage.
Über mir ist ein Dude.
Alter, oh nee, jetzt steht er da mit seinem Stellens-Auto rum.
Hier, weißt du was?
Scheiß drauf, wir spielen ja kein TDM hier.
Hallo? Game, please.
Von hinten, alter.
Ey, geh...
Ey, wir haben eben, wir haben eben, äh, wir haben eben Nosha gespielt.
Fuck.
Die stehen da schon ganz gut.
Aber das sind doch mehr als 16 versus 16 hier, oder?
Du hast an jeder Ecke gefühlt einen Klumpen aus 50 Milliarden Gegnern.
Guck dir das mal an.
An jeder Ecke hast du 50 Milliarden Gegner.
Das ist ziemlich normales Gameplay.
Das ist ja auch kein Killstreak-Server oder sonst was.
Ich würde halt echt gerne mal auf dem Killstreak-Server spielen.
Guck dir das mal an, das sind doch keine 16 versus 16.
Im Leben nicht.
Squads, gute Idee.
Na doch, doch.
Anscheinend schon.
Aber das ist doch nicht normal gerade hier.
Gibt, gibt dem aber einen Server und ist das eine Frage oder meinst du das jetzt, äh, ist das eine Aussage?
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht normal gerade.
Aussage.
Ah, ohne Blaufilter, den probieren wir gleich mal aus.
Das ist...
Kriegen wir hier nicht normalerweise ein Auto?
Äh, gleich mal die M16 am Start.
Die Leute sind heiß und rennen rein, sieht so aus.
Es fühlt sich überhaupt nicht an wie 16 versus 16.
Von normalerweise so weit vorne, äh, das kann nicht sein.
Wie sieht es eigentlich mit Anti-Cheat bei wenigstens Licht aus?
Gibt es da irgendwas?
Haben wir normalerweise nicht ein Auto hier?
Oh, zu wenig Tickets.
Kein Anti-Cheat.
Ja gut, also es kommt drauf an, wenn die gute Server-Admins haben, brauchst du...
Naja, also ganz ohne Anti-Cheat ist doof, aber...
Ohne, ähm...
Ja, also, da kommst du ganz gut mit aus.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal, was es sonst noch für Server gibt.
Ja, du brauchst auf jeden Fall eine Custom-Version.
Oh, Grand Bazaar.
Grand Bazaar Team Death Punch wird immer anstrengender.
Operation Metro, Rush, Demoman Peak.
Simba Randomizer Rush Server, okay.
Wo ist denn Killstreak?
Ich will nochmal diesen Killstreak-Server spielen, Alter.
Das war richtig nice.
Filter, konnte man suchen?
Server-Admin, gibt's einen?
Krieg?
Genau, keine Sicherheits-Kopie, du brauchst ein legit Game.
Grand Bazaar, Rush...
Ah, das war kein 16 vs 16, wie gesagt, das war...
Filter nach Tags... Tagsucht?
Ah.
Ah!
Aha!
Sham-Off Server, Mods on.
Grand Bazaar, Conquest Large.
Ping.
Excellent.
Okay, es gibt keinen Killstreak-Server, den man spielen kann.
Ich habe keine DLCs gerade installiert.
Official Killstreak-Server, bye.
Wie gesagt, also bei Tags Killstreak gibt's nichts.
Nichts, was man spielen kann.
99%, das ist ja nichts.
Spiel doch die neue Metro-Map.
Es gibt eine neue Metro-Map?
Ach, du meinst die mit dem See?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es da einen Custom-Server für gibt.
Rush Classics.
USA East.
Was spielen wir da jetzt mal?
Bazaar TDM, Alter.
Der obere ist meiner.
Äh, okay, okay, Moment.
Du meinst den da?
Der da?
Vinkov Gizk.
Ja gut, ich habe gerade keinen DLC installiert.
Such mal nach Box Game.
Da zeige ich mal hin.
Box Game.
Okay, also muss man...
Groß- und Kleinschreibung hier.
Okay, die Suche funktioniert schon mal gar nicht.
Box Game.
Wow, was ist das?
Server ist voll.
Excellent.
A von Acht.
Box Game, Minigame.
Lass mich drauf.
Minecraft.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie Minecraft, ja.
Minigame.
Gibt's nur das.
Also, wir haben...
Na, drei Spieler, das ist viel zu krass, ey.
Terran Highway, Conquest.
Na, 48, das kann man wirklich halbwegs spielen, ey.
Grand Bazaar.
Conquest.
Okay, auf geht's.
Ja, wir probieren noch ein paar andere Mods.
Klar, also...
Oh, was ist das?
Das ist der Warzone-Kompass, Leute.
Guck mal, das ist der Warzone-Kompass.
Was soll der jetzt in Battlefield genau bringen?
Alter, wie...
Ey, du kommst ja wieder vorwärts.
Ist der ohne Blaufilter?
Nee, oder? Ist der ohne Blaufilter?
Ist der ohne Blaufilter? Ich kann's jetzt...
Das könnte ohne Blaufilter sein.
So wirklich den Unterschied erkenne ich jetzt aber nicht,
wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Es sieht ein bisschen bunter aus.
Schon richtig, ja.
Hallo.
Fuck.
Es sieht ein bisschen...
Ja, das Original-Game ist tot.
Und hier hast du die Chance,
dass sich ein paar coole Sachen entwickeln.
Ey, gut.
Suppression kommt auf den Server an, ne?
Hallo. Deploy. Deploy.
Top.
Also, die...
Wenn das jetzt ja gleich funktionieren wird...
Okay.
Auf, komm raus.
Streck deinen Kopf raus, Alter.
Alter, die kippen ja links und rechts um.
Hier kommst du aber auch nicht raus, ne?
Oh, jetzt machen sie Push-A-Reno.
Oh, Alter, ist das ein Clusterfuck gerade.
Du brauchst keine Lizenz.
Du musst einfach Origin
und wenn es unleashed gleichzeitig starten.
Hallo. Deploy.
Kann man hier hinten lang?
Ich spiel nie Conquest.
Ihr wisst, dass ich der übelste Conquest-Noob bin.
Kriegst gleich in die Fresse geleuchtet, ey.
Kommt ein Panzer.
Ehrlich, ist alles voll mit LAVs.
Der muss jetzt eigentlich aussteigen, der Dude.
Peace.
Okay, ich muss zurück.
Ich muss, ich muss, ich muss weg.
Keine Chance, ey.
Wieso will man einen Blaufilter?
Weiß ich nicht.
Warum?
Warum soll man einen Blaufilter holen?
Oder warum nicht?
Ah, muss doch jeder wissen.
Also, ich muss euch sagen.
Ich finde den Blaufilter gar nicht so übel.
Das macht das Gaming wie ausgemacht.
Alter.
Wie schnell stirbst du denn hier?
Ist der übelst heftig, ey.
Was, stuttering?
Ne, also bei mir stuttert nix.
Sag mal so, man muss sich da mit Sicherheit erst mal dran gewöhnen.
Das ist Conquest.
Da kannst du hier kein One-Man-Rumbo-Dings spielen wie in Rush.
Hopp, hopp, hopp.
Ach, das ist der Rush-Spawn hier vorne, ne?
Ich hab legit 5 Minuten Conquest-Spielzeit oder so in dem Spiel.
Ich glaub, hier geht's gar nicht lang.
Wir waren jetzt einfach...
Wir campen jetzt einfach immer ne Runde.
Die flanken bestimmt rüber.
Moin, Propain.
Excellent.
Du wirst aber auch wieder heftig um die Ecke getroffen.
Okay, wie funktioniert denn der...
Wie funktioniert denn der Conquest-Flow so?
Ja, ja, Game!
Hallo?
Was war das denn jetzt?
3 Stunden durchgeschossen.
Kack-Kack-Quadrupilio.
Das ist jetzt n wenigstens ein Leashed-Surfer, ja?
Okay, wir campen jetzt einfach hier in der Ecke.
Easy.
Oh, oh, oh, was da hier los?
Von hinten kommt was angestellst.
Wir rennen jetzt einfach bis hinten hinunter.
Alter, wir sind ja voll im...
voll im Sandwich, äh...
Megasandwich.
Poggersandwich.
Boah, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Pogger-Sandwich.
Alter, was ist jetzt los?
Habt ihr gesehen? Es ist voll am Abkacken gewesen gerade.
Alter, was geht mit meiner Waffe ab?
Ist doch nicht normal.
Du bist auf einem guten Server mit Killstreaks.
Ja, da will ich auch hin.
Exzellent.
Äh, Sprinten.
Das ist eine gute Frage, ob man Sprinten toggeln kann.
Weiß nicht.
Glaube nicht.
Ich glaube, das gab es nicht.
Ich glaube, wir müssen Control halten.
Oh, das ist mega laggy gerade, ey.
Es wackelt total rum.
Ganz merkwürdig.
Und manchmal setzt auch das Springen aus.
Ihr seht es ja auch beim Fahren jetzt.
Krasser Lag-Scheiß.
Alter, lass mich doch.
Ja, dann nicht.
Oh, seht ihr, wie das ruckelt?
Ohne Scheiß.
Seht ihr das?
Oh.
Fuck, Alter.
WTF?
Das ist huge am laggen.
Am Box-Server sind gerade vier Slots frei.
Okay, okay.
Probieren wir mal.
Ich probiere den Box-Server mal aus.
Ist wieder voll.
Lull.
Entweder war das G-Bait oder die Leute waren einfach schneller.
Fühlst du denn jetzt, wenn es anleischt?
Ich fühle aktuell gerade lag.
So, gucken wir mal.
Killstreaks.
Gibt es eigentlich eine Server-Queue?
Oh, Killstreaks-Server.
Grand Bazaar Conquest Killstreaks.
Jawoll.
Das fühlen wir jetzt, Leute.
Digga.
Das, Digga, das mit so einem Gefühl.
Select Killstreaks.
Okay.
Im Prinzip alle.
Game?
Ah, das ist gerade vorbei.
Kann das sein, dass das Game auch bei großen Servern nicht in der Lage ist, mehr als 16 anzuzeigen?
Schon merkwürdig, dass immer 16 Leute drin sind auf beiden Seiten.
Obwohl angeblich irgendwie 53 oder so drin sind.
Komisch.
Wahrscheinlich ist das wahrscheinlich jetzt alles ein bisschen, ja, ne, aber guck mal, hier steht, aber hier steht 15, 16 drin, angeblich waren es irgendwie 53 oder sowas.
Ach, Serveranschaltungen sind falsch, okay.
Du brauchst keine Lizenz-Key.
Du musst einfach Origin und wenn es anleischt gleichzeitig starten und gut ist.
Ah, jetzt könnten wir einen Panzer haben.
Ist das Luftabwehr?
Ich glaube, das ist Luftabwehr, oder?
Komm, wir fahren Auto.
Oh, was.
Luftabwehr will keiner.
Und da vorne kommt jetzt gleich der Panzerman an.
Mit dem Auto in den LLV.
Big Brain Logik, ja.
Top.
Okay, ich rappe jetzt unseren LLV.
Okay, jetzt erspielen wir uns mal ein paar Killstreaks.
Excellent Killstreaks.
Gehen wir mal ans andere Fenster, dass man ein bisschen was sieht.
Okay, ich steig mal aus.
Oh, da war ein Gegner.
Oh, KS.
Wo kommt hier was?
Wie weit sind hier eigentlich die Capture-Regionen?
Gehen die weit?
Oder wie weit gehen die?
Flak Capture.
Leute, ich habe jetzt nicht aufgepasst.
Sind Scorestreaks, oder?
Sind Scorestreaks mit...
Ich kenne halt null den Flow von Conquest, ne?
Sind so viele Conquest-Stellserver unterwegs?
Muss ich ein bisschen Conquest lernen?
Ich habe nicht das Conquest-Mindset.
Das ist richtig.
Ah.
Rats, please.
Gib Rats.
Nope.
Kein Rats.
Gib kein Rats.
Rats deny.
Guck mal, guck mal.
Ich habe Killstreaks.
Smokescreen?
Was macht Adrenalin Rush?
Äh.
Okay.
Ich habe jetzt Adrenalin Rush an.
Oh, habt ihr den Damage gesehen?
Ich habe einfach nur die Gegner gesprengt.
Bam.
Okay, Adrenalin Rush macht mir mehr Damage.
Okay, okay.
Achtung, Achtung.
Jetzt, bam.
Adrenalin Rush an.
Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam.
Okay.
Oder auch nicht.
Oder auch doch nicht.
Hätte ja sein können.
Geh mal auf Soldier.
Ich blicke hier nicht mehr durch.
Alter, es ist mir zu viel.
Das ist zu viel.
Was ist hier los?
Oh.
Perfekte Nade.
Massive.
Perfekte Nades.
Alter Falter, was ist denn hier los?
Da sitzt.
Auch von hinten.
Die ganzen M16s.
Na klar.
Muss.
Hier ist richtig was los.
Guck mal, da ist ein Auto.
Da spawnen wir jetzt nochmal in die MG rein.
Die M16 ist die beste Waffe im ganzen Game.
Ja, okay.
Dann.
Nicht.
Ja, so.
Das funktioniert so nichts.
Nice.
Komm, wir können da in den Gang reinschießen.
Wir können.
Lass uns in den Gang reinschießen.
In den Gang reinschießen, Alter.
Gang schieß so aus.
Ah.
Ja.
Fast.
Ich habe jetzt eigentlich eher gedacht von da hinten aus so.
Hehehe.
Was gibt es, wenn es fertig ist?
Es gibt keine Entfernung.
Ich habe es schon nicht gesehen.
Ja, gut.
Okay, ich habe es jetzt nicht gesehen.
Okay.
Es gibt keine Entfernung.
Was teknisch.
Das wohl auch nicht.
Okay.
Ich bin so.
Wir gehen in der Richtung.
Was machen wir?
Den Ball.
Hey, ey.
Ist gut.
Ist ja gut.
Kommt, fahr hier nicht rein.
Fahr woanders hin.
die vier. Easy.
Ja, wenn du
den presst, kannst du genau die vier Killstreaks
auswählen, die ich hab.
Mehr gibt's nicht. Aber ich
geh mal davon aus, dass es demnächst noch mehr geben wird.
Aber Modding Support
ist wirklich ein Segen für das Game, ich sag's
euch. Ohne Mist.
Ohne Mist.
Nice. Achtung, Achtung, vorhin.
Modding Support, echt
ein Segen für das Game.
Nice. Gleich haben wir,
Leute, gleich haben wir unsere Artillery,
unseren Artillery-Strike am Start.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Wow, oh, oh, was man da Artillery-Striken
kann.
Jetzt rekt. Alter.
Hardcore rekt.
Okay, nix mehr da.
Okay, in die Hotspots. Okay, eins
hab ich kapiert, Kongfest, man rennt nicht in die Hotspots
denn los rein.
Nein, nein, nein. Jawoll.
Kommst du raus?
Der Dude lebt da noch, oder?
Oder auch nicht? Okay.
Also, wie gesagt, ihr braucht Origin,
also ihr braucht eine Originalversion, sonst geht das
nicht. Und dann, wenn es
uns
so zusammenstattet. Ah!
Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam!
Alter, in your face!
Nehmt es mal auf, das kann man bestimmt gut für ein Video
verwenden, wegen den Killstreaks.
Wie hier ist. Oh, hinter uns.
Irgendwo hinter uns war grad was.
Oh nein, nein! Please, nicht wieder!
Nicht wieder!
Aber eins muss man dem Fahrer lassen, er ist hartnäckig.
Er ist hartnäckig.
Und jetzt steht hinter uns der Panzer. Okay, es wird ja immer besser.
Und jetzt ist ein LLV hinter uns.
Okay, ich brauch noch 70. 70, dann kommt die Artillery.
70, dann kommt die Artillery, Leute.
Gleich kommt die Artillery.
Artillery, F8.
Press 9? F9?
Hab ich doch, F9. Ah! F8?
F5?
Okay.
Okay, ich hab die Artillery enabled. Ich hab keinen blassen Schimmer,
was jetzt passiert ist.
Wo ist die Artillery hin?
Ist das ein Bug?
Ist das ein Bug, den ich grad gefunden hab?
Hab ich grad enge...
Ich glaub, du hast gesmoked. Okay.
Ah, ich muss aus dem Fahrzeug raus. Okay.
Dann holen wir gleich nochmal
die nächste Artillery.
Oh.
Nein, nein, nein.
Komm hier nochmal raus, Kollege. Komm nochmal raus.
Okay, F8
F9
Und jetzt? Und jetzt? Alter, F9
Hä?
Okay, okay
Ich probier's jetzt nochmal in Ruhe
Okay
Spawn
Post-Jump, okay, also was
F8
Okay, F9
Hm
Ich glaub so ganz funktioniert's noch nicht, oder?
Oh, doch
Hä?
Hat das jetzt artilleriert?
Okay, Smokescreen
Wow
Hab ich jetzt gesmoked?
Hä?
Hat das jetzt gesmoked?
So ganz hab ich's noch nicht verstanden
Das hat doch nicht gesmoked
Da war doch gar nix
Okay, okay, Moment, Smoke
Und jetzt F9
F5
Aha
Okay
Was auch immer
Ich, also ich würd sagen
Die, die Bedienung
Könnte man eventuell noch ein bisschen optimieren
Was passiert eigentlich
Wenn ich nur ein Killstreak auswähle?
Okay, Grenades
F5
Ach guck mal, ich hab 8 Granaten
Lull
Das ist ja geil
Oh, das ist ja der Spam-Poggers des Todes
8 Granaten
8 Granaten-Spam, Alter
Huge
Metro-Kill-Züg 8 Nades
Guckt euch das mal an
Das ist ne coole Sache, das gefällt mir
Also, Smoking-Artill dauert 7 Sekunden
Da kommt der auch
Ja, aber, was ich noch nicht verstanden hab, ist
Also, so wie ich das jetzt versteh, ist
Ähm
So wie ich das jetzt verstanden hab, ist
Du drückst erstmal F8
So, dann kommt so'n Platzieren
So'n Platzieren-Feld
Dann drückst du F9, um das Platzieren-Feld zu
Ähm, bestätigen
Und dann musst du nochmal F5 drücken
Oder so
Das, wann drückst du was, das hab ich noch nicht genau verstanden
Overlay-Poggers-Auto-Auto-Gefahren, ey
Massive-Auto-Gefahren
500 IQ Driver
Du solltest den eigenen Film kriegen
Du musst warten, oben rechts kann einer best-
Oh, das hab ich im Eifer des Gefechts gar nicht gesehen
Achso, nein, nur F8 dann
Und wie aim ich die Artillerie?
Was'n des? Was zum?
Was'n des für'ne Map?
Das ist Dings, das ist Armored-Kill-Map
Ich hab doch gar kein DLC installiert
Allboards Mountain ist das
Allboards Mountain
Okay, auf
Gehen wir mal in irgend so'n
So'n L.A.V. rein hier
Auf, ich brauch irgendeinen, der
Keine Ahnung, der
Nee, geh mal nicht rein
Ich fahr damit
Wär halt gut, wenn ich Engineer wär
Was'n des?
Oh, das ist Luftabwehr
Luftabwehr suckt, ey
Äh, 77 MB hat das
Du brauchst das originale Spiel
Overly bist du raus?
Die Map kenn ich ja mal gar nicht, ey
Hat man ne Map? Ja, super
Super hilfreich, Battlefield, exzellent
Erstmal voll hinten reinfahren
Bam, alter
Aber hier ist das Spiel abgestürzt
Ey, Leute
Ihr dürft absolut nichts erwarten, grad ich kenn die Map nicht
Ich kenn den Spielmodus auf der Map nicht
Ich kenn den Spielmodus nicht, ey, relativ wenig
Anzeige ist raus
Konnt man nicht
Irgendwie hupen auch?
Ah, sind Vögel
Mit N kannst du raus? Ah, ah
Ist mal hier
Oh
War das ein Heli-Stelzer?
Ich fahr jetzt einfach mal den Berg hoch
Oh, die haben nen AC
AC-130 am Start
Bam
Äh, war ich das?
Nee, oder? Das war vorher schon kaputt
Das war ich nicht
TH hast du kein PC?
Hä? Ich dachte du spielst Dings
Äh, Valorant
Competitive Valorant auf PC
Oh, Moment
Nehmen die gerade E ein?
Nehmen die da unten gerade E ein?
Max
Legendary Driver Skills
Oh, ne
Legendary Driver
Oh, wo ist
Ah, hier
Alter, Max mit der Luftabwehr
Ich muss das Ding irgendwo stehen lassen
Ja, mit der Granate
könnt ihr mir nix machen
Das sind zwei
Das sind zwei Medics gewesen, ne?
Zwei Medics, null
Wo, wo, wo
Wo ist hier was?
Ich muss mit meiner Luftabwehr irgendwas bashen
Wo ist hier überhaupt hinten und vorne, ey?
Moment, ist das vorne und das hinten gerade?
Fahr ich gerade falsch rum?
Ah, ich fahr gerade falsch rum, kann das sein?
Excellent
Huge Driver Skills
Massive Drivers
Man sieht, wie oft ich
diesen Motorspiel, vor allem wie oft ich dieses Ding fahr, ey
Ey, kommt hier nochmal irgendeiner
Okay, scheiß drauf
Egal, ich hau jetzt ab
Easy
War jetzt zu arg
Kann das mal explodieren?
Ah, es ist schon explodiert
Oh, oh, Panzer
Panzer schießt auf mich
Von wo schießt der Panzer auf mich?
Okay, da ist ein Flieger
Du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du
Und, und
Kriegen wir ihn?
Ah, yes
Max in der AA fühl ich richtig
Oh, und ich erst, ja
Okay
Wir fahren jetzt, wir fahren jetzt Panzer mit
Wie viel passen denn da rein?
Deswegen mag ich
keinen Conquest, ey
Da stellst du dir ewig einen ab
Flieg mal, nein, nein
Ich spiel Infanterie
Infanterie ist das, was mir Bock macht an dem Game
Woah
Ist ja gut
Übertreibs, übertreibs, ja
Äh
War hier grad nicht ein Gegner?
Oh Geiss
Alter, diese Map und dieser Modus
Das macht mich ja fertig
Komm, bevor ich spiel, spiel ich das Game zum ersten Mal, ja
Auch heute
Ah, ey
Achtung, Achtung
Post-Champ, Post-Champ, Post-Champ
Hey, das war gar nicht so schlecht, müsst ihr zugeben
Stellts da noch ein Typ rum
Achtung, Skillshot
Q-Chat hat 3-1
Aber die Gegner sind auch nicht besser
Sag mal, ist da einer über uns gerade
Ist da einer über uns
Über uns gerade gefallschirm
Jetzt hätte ich Adrenalin Rush machen müssen
Und die bashen, alter
Hier, Adrenalin Rush
Und jetzt, und jetzt, bam, bam, bam, bam
Okay, bringt ja gar nix, ey
Okay, wir machen Smokescreen, Leute
Smokescreen
Bam, 9
Ah, jetzt
Smoke Impact in
Massive Smoke
Massive Smoke hier
Jetzt hab ich uns selbst eingesmoked
Das war natürlich äußerst
Äußerst
High IQ
Achtung, easy, easy flank, easy flank, easy flank
Bam
Ihr rekt
So, 14 aufheben
So muss das sein
Die Sonne
Die macht dich auch fertig
Okay, ich glaub, ne Artillery kriegen wir nicht mehr hier
Ich glaub, ne Artillery kriegen wir die Runde nicht
Wo ist der Dude?
Irgendwo dahinter, oder?
Achtung, der Benni
Ne, Ben, BenBit
Easy, komm, wir rushen den jetzt weg
Ach, da war er
Tatsächlich, der lebt ja noch
Mehr, mehr Sonnen-Flares
Please
Sag mal, Chat, geht euch das auch so, dass ihr die Entfernung überhaupt nicht richtig abschätzen könnt auf der Miniman?
Ha
Lul
Ist da noch einer?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
Was jetzt?
Server stirbt
Äh, meine Killstreaks sind weg
Meine Killstreaks wurden gerade resettet
Und jetzt gehen meine Killstreaks nicht mehr
Und die Killstreaks sind kaputt
Die Killstreaks sind weg
Ich, ich kann nicht mehr
Ich kann nicht mehr
Ich, ich
Ich mach keine Progression-Punkte mehr
Admin hat mich
Hat Killstreak bunt, genau
What the hell
Ah, okay, vielleicht, wenn man stirbt
Vielleicht, wenn man stirbt, okay
Okay, ich hab's probiert
Ich hab's probiert, Leute
Ich habe es probiert
Na, ich muss da hoch
Game, please
Lass mich hüppen
Ne, ich krieg keine Punkte mehr
Ich krieg keine Killstreak-Punkte mehr
Aber schon hart unfair, ne
Kann man die hier hochstelzen, irgendwie?
Oh, nice
Flankerino
Siehst du, der wäre immer bei mir lang gelaufen, Jungs
Battlefield, Battlefield, please
Lass mich drüber
Die waren doch eben noch hier
Da war er
Hallo, please
Da ist er doch, sag ich doch
Was des? Was des?
Ah, das ist ja gar nicht mein Kit
Das ist ja gar nicht mein Kit
Lull
Oh, ich hab's doch gesehen
Oh, ne, wo ist denn der? Oben, unten, oben?
Der ist oben, oder?
Alter, Alter
Naja, ist ja mit Spaß hält
sich gerade ein bisschen in Grenzen, weil ich keine Killstreaks
mehr bekomme, aus welchen Gründen auch immer
Weil wir einen Spiel-Modus
und eine Map spielen, die ich keine Ahnung von hab
Okay, select kills, wir machen das noch mal anders
Ich mach's nochmal weg
So, mach ich wieder dran
Vielleicht krieg ich jetzt Punkte
Nein, ich bin ja wieder
Ich kack, rup
wieder gespawnt als als angie wollte ich gar nicht. Entschuldige. Ah ne das ist auch angie.
na gut dann kann ich. ok mal gucken ob ich jetzt wieder punkte krieg. ah mods reloaded
ok verstehe verstehe. oh bulletproof tent. ok das heißt wir müssen auf nächste runde warten
dann geht es wieder. sehe ich das richtig? das heißt gerade bekommt keiner killstreaks.
äh. excellent. excellent. excellent excellent. rauf rauf. oh da vorne steht ein panzer.
ich glaube das ist keine Gute idee wenn wir das jetzt ranstelzen. versuch den mal. geht
Guck hier.
Komm ich da irgendwie hoch?
Wahrscheinlich.
Da war noch was.
Ey, das ist unser Dude.
Okay, kann man hier klettern?
Oh, wie knapp.
Das war knapp.
Oh, das war auch knapp.
Kannst ja mal probieren.
Da ist unser Chopper.
Oh ne, AC-130 am Start.
Achtung, massive skillshot.
Was passiert hier gerade um mich?
Oh, guckt es euch mal an, wie knapp.
Ich spawne jetzt halt was anderes als Engie.
Das funktioniert gerade nicht.
Richtig close.
Richtig.
Oh, da steht ein Panzer direkt vor der Ecke.
Ey, ne, ne.
Es wird zu viel auf einmal gerade hier.
What the fuck?
Also hier oben ist man echt nicht...
Ey, das ist nicht normal gerade.
Kannst du das nicht wirklich spielen?
Das ist, sag mal, das ist dieser Mobile-Artillery-Typ.
Oh, zum Glück ist die Runde vorbei, ey.
Boah.
Kann man eigentlich Server als Favorites setzen?
Aber immerhin, Q-Chat führt.
Q-Chat, Q-Chat-Squad am Start.
GD eats.
Nein, der Pog-Champer.
Ich fände Pog-Camper eigentlich viel besser.
Ohne 3D-Spotting sieht man fast nichts.
Das ist richtig.
Ist das aus?
Also ich würde eigentlich...
Wenn ich einen Server mache,
ich werde am eigentlichen Base-Gameplay nichts ändern.
Ich werde vielleicht Killstreaks dazu machen,
je nachdem, vielleicht wenn man das abhängig machen kann,
wie es mit Metro aussieht.
Spiel mal die neue Metro-Map.
Mach ich, mach ich.
Ich gucke erst mal, was in der nächsten Runde kommt.
Metro-Map.
Nochmal.
Oh, ne.
Oh, ne, nicht noch.
Ne, ne.
Nochmal, Alborz Mountain muss nicht sein.
So, also Metro.
Wo kann man die neue Metro-Map spielen?
Gibt es da einen Filter?
Filter?
Minigame.
Was gibt es denn da eigentlich?
Probieren wir mal aus.
Such mal nach Lake.
Alles klar, mach ich.
Jetzt probieren wir erst mal das Metro-Minigame aus.
What the?
Und jetzt?
What?
Cute Chat Wins.
Ich habe gewonnen, Leute.
Ich habe gewonnen.
Habt ihr es gesehen?
Cute Chat Wins.
Null.
Jetzt verstehe ich es.
Jetzt verstehe ich es ja erst.
Man muss den Boden wegschießen.
Okay, Achtung, Achtung.
Wir machen jetzt rein.
Rush, Rush, Rush, Rush.
Jawoll.
Ich habe ihn.
Bam.
Oh, was für ein Schwachsinn, Alter.
Okay, das kann ich nicht.
Okay, das kann man ein paar Runden spielen, aber lang ist es.
Dann spielen wir jetzt die neue Metro-Map.
Eigentlich lustig, ja.
Aber da sieht man, was möglich ist.
Was man alles Cooles machen kann.
Geh mal auf den Zwei-Box-Server.
Mach ich gleich.
Ach, schon werden sie gebasht, Alter.
Und tschüss.
Ist ganz witzig, aber auf Dauer nichts.
Free-for-all-Flat.
Was ist das?
Wieder was anderes.
Probieren wir mal den aus.
Rush-Metro.
Aber das ist ja nicht wirklich Rush-Metro.
Das ist ja was anderes.
Ist klar.
Post-Champ, Post-Champ.
Wollt ihr sagen, ich habe mich gerade selbst runtergeschossen.
Das klappt nicht.
Das glaube ich euch nicht, Chat.
Kann nicht sein.
Moment, das ist doch genau das Gleiche.
Das wird zu dumm.
Das ist dumm.
Okay.
Das ist das neue Metro, genau.
Ich kann übrigens nicht quitten gerade.
Das kann ich auf Dauer nicht spielen.
Okay.
Nach was soll ich suchen?
Nach sie?
Ration-Metro-Sea-Tester.
Ach, das ist das Metro.
Jetzt habe ich Sea gesucht, aber Sea ging auch.
Oder auch nicht.
Oder doch?
Oder nicht?
Nein.
Lake soll ich suchen.
Lake.
Gibt es nicht.
Kein Lake.
Lake großgeschrieben.
Stop.
Ah.
I.
Ernsthaft?
Großkleinschreibung?
Kek-W.
Wer baut denn sowas mit Großkleinschreibung?
126 Ping, ja egal, egal, egal.
Ah, wir haben gerade verloren.
Auch gut.
Press?
Nein, ich will niemand bannen.
Ich habe neulich mal gegen den gespielt, was dieses Windows-Firewall-Ding ist.
Ja, das macht was.
Das blockt zum Beispiel eingehende Verbindungen auf deinem Rechner, die du aber normalerweise
eh nicht von außen hast, weil du hinter deinem Router bist.
Hast du das Ding?
Ja.
Overwatch 2 League gesehen? Nee. Geht das gerade schon los? Ich disconnecte mal und gehe wieder neu rein.
Ach, der lädt vielleicht die neue Map, wobei die Map ist ja ingame drin.
Ah, jetzt. Easy. Nein, ich bin schon wieder endig gespawnt. Warum spawne ich denn? Schreck mich nicht so.
Okay. Nice. Guck mal, man spielt wirklich Conquest Metro außen. Das heißt, man kann
jetzt Rush Spawn Trap in Conquest machen. So ist es ja nice. By the way, mit meiner
P90 komme ich hier natürlich richtig gut. Richtig gut mit der P90, Alter. Richtig nice.
P90 Master Race. Beste. Okay, jetzt kann ich endlich als Medic spawnen. Das ist übrigens
sehr nice, dass man mit der P90 spawnt. Das ist übrigens sehr nice, dass man mit der P90 spawnt. Das ist übrigens sehr nice, dass man mit der
Metro an einer anderen Stelle spielen kann. Finde ich richtig cool.
Okay, Squad Cover haben wir schon. Dann nehme ich Squad Ammo. Where is my Pluton?
Wisst ihr was? Das sieht jetzt ohne Scheiß... Man erkennt jetzt erst mal, wie gut das
Spiel überhaupt aussieht. Ich meine, das hatten wir vorher auch schon gesehen, aber das Spiel sah halt echt gut aus für die
damalige Zeit. Und ich habe kleine... Was heißt kleine? Ich habe Minimal-Settings.
Minimal-Settings, ne?
Minimal-Settings. Ich habe gerade so ein bisschen ein Problem, vorwärts zu kommen.
Ach, ich habe vergessen, in den Büschen kann man nicht retzen. Haha, 0. 0 W. So. Ey, hier ist ja nicht normal.
Okay, den kann man wieder nicht retzen. Okay, die Map ist nicht auf Spielbarkeit gebalanced. Das ist ja ein
Sniper-Fest, sondersgleichen. Wie viel Mann ist eigentlich drauf? 48, ne? Oder? 48? Ui, guck mal,
guck mal, es gibt... accuse Gustsm Spawnbildschirm-Anzeige. Oh, das ist cool, das muss ich mir Hey, du bist als
Anzeiger...
Uh, das ist das coole. Das muss ich mir mal speichern.
Ben syrup, das stimmt.
Excellent!
Good Reading, große Miss-Mits chu.
Exzzgelent...
Good Reading, Enterprise.
Good Reading, Enterprise. Exquisite!
Mit der Rex in den Kopf hat er mir ...
Good Reading, Enterprise.
...
Skills schoss.
Good Reading, Enterprise.
Muss mal kurz gucken. Der MASH sollte heute mit spielen, oder?
Hey, K сделали.
Nice 2021.
You!
mal gehört da ist ja einer ok ok 1 fällt mir jetzt auf man sieht die
gegner mit ohne plautin schlechter gibt es eigentlich kann gute frage nächste
frage man sieht die gegner schlechter ohne plautin sie sehen ungewohnt aus auf
jeden fall machen sie rush action wo ist der dude what also entweder sind die
super super krassen dudes am start ach der saß direkt hinter dem teil doch doch
du kannst den donaten mir nicht mehr mehr ich bin
donierte lieber den mod herstellern veniceunleashed.net und da
kannst du gucken was man machen kann
kann es sein dass die uns fucking dominierten gerade wir haben nicht eine
flag ok das ist ja sniper sniper herren gerade so viele schneidermanns ok ok
leute ich sehe dass das land verlangt nach einem ordentlichen rush server
das heißt ich werde mich heute abend mal damit beschäftigen wie man server
installiert oder ich kaufe mir einfach einen server bei dem bei dem offiziellen
hoster da machen wir einen gescheiten killstreak rush server ich sag's euch
leute
beste world first und nachdem wir auch den killstreak entwickler hier im chat
haben wir das noch viel leiser ordentlicher rush server braucht das land
können wir capturen jetzt capturen please weil vielleicht kriegen wir noch ein
bisschen paar punkte wobei das hier mit killstreaks bestimmt auch cool wäre
denke ich mir so gerade
what?
ok das ist gut
Das stimmt doch irgendwas nicht.
Was war denn das gerade?
Ach, der stand einfach da.
Ist hier teilweise so random von jeder Ecke.
Down.
Könnt ihr mir nicht erzählen, ne?
Okay, jetzt wird gerusht.
So, wo ist er?
Alter, von wo schießt der denn jetzt schon wieder was?
Ey, die wollen mich echt rollen, ne?
Dann müssen wir Zickzack-Kurs machen, dann geht's.
Zickzack-Bash.
Massive, Zickzack.
Ja.
Easy.
Jetzt Killstreaks, jetzt den Artillery-Strike da hinten rein, ey.
Jetzt den Artillery-Strike, bam.
Wir wollen Rush spielen, aber es gibt keine gescheiten Rush-Server.
Es gibt nur Damovan Peak.
Der leckt as fuck.
Okay, aber das ist schon geil, dass sie hinten auf der Map das spielt, oder?
Das ist schon cool, das ist schon cool.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo die sind.
Oh, nee, stimmt, in Büschen kann man ja nicht retzen.
Okay, okay, Leute, dazu fällt mir nur eins ein.
Please, Boot fahren.
Es gibt, glaube ich, gar kein Boot.
Doch, da ist ein Boot.
Okay, okay, wir fahren kurz Boot.
Auf dem Boot kann man nicht spawnen, okay, das suckt.
Ach, nix, wir fahren jetzt Boot.
Easy.
Ja, ist klar, nicht sterben, please.
Jetzt aber.
Nice.
Wir haben es gerissen, Leute.
Ich weiß gar nicht, von wo ich her war.
Zumindest sind das ziemlich pepega Sniper.
Auf dem Boot wird man sofort weggeklappt.
Ja, das ist nicht so wirklich balanced.
Aber macht ja nix.
Macht ja nix.
Aber ich find's nice, hier draußen die Metro.
Gefällt mir.
Es ist aber halt Sniper-fest, ne?
Ist halt richtig hart Sniper-fest.
Also, wer gern sniped in dem Game, der, der wird hier einer abgehen.
Jetzt scheint's, ja, jetzt geht's.
Leute, ich hab übelst Hunger wieder.
Ich bin schon on.
Er ist 3,30, kommt mir gar nicht so kurz vor.
Sniper vs. Shotgun.
Nee, ich glaub, Shotgun kommst du auf der Map nicht wirklich weiter.
Okay.
Okay, das ist ja anscheinend only...
Hallo?
Nein!
Okay.
Ich glaub, ich glaub, das ist Stream-Ende.
Wenn ich jetzt nicht mehr reinkomm.
Okay, easy.
Okay, was haben wir denn sonst noch zu bieten hier?
Hab ich Filter rausgenommen?
All Maps, DLC, DLC.
Okay, Rush.
Es gibt halt, es gibt halt kein Rush, ne?
Danke schön für den Sub, NS7.
Emotes, Rush.
Prop Hunt!
Es gibt Prop Hunt?
Okay, das ist, das ist nice.
Das müssen wir mal irgendwann im Stream ausprobieren.
Da kann man sich auf Siebertower als Stuhl verstecken.
Da hab ich ja drauf gewartet.
Okay, Leute, Rush, Rush, Rush gibt's nicht.
Spielt keiner.
Day-Night-Cycle, cool.
Gibt kein Rush.
So, aber jetzt, bevor wir...
Team Deathmatch, Close Quarters.
Also, bevor wir Schluss machen, Leute, was meint ihr?
Hat das Potenzial?
Was sagt ihr?
Ja.
Ich mein, mehr Server als offiziell.
Auf jeden Fall hat's schon mal...
Auf jeden, ja, find ich auch.
Es braucht halt auf...
Das ist übrigens das, das ist übrigens das, was ich als...
Was ich ja schon die ganze Zeit gesagt hab und auch in meinem Video gesagt hab.
Gesagt hab, es reicht nicht, wenn du ein cooles Basis-Ding hast, was du rausbringst zu Release.
Weil die normalen Spieler, also die, äh, halt die potenziellen Leute, die noch Battlefield 3 spielen,
die werden nicht so sehr dadurch jetzt hergelockt,
weil es in Zukunft vielleicht mal...
Einen geilen Mod gibt oder so.
Das muss von Anfang an...
Muss da was Geiles da sein, sonst funktioniert's nicht.
Die Killstreak-Geschichte ist auf jeden Fall sehr nice.
Auch wenn ich's nicht geschafft hab, eine Artillery auszulösen.
Merkt man die 60 oder 120 Hertz?
Ja, ja.
Wenn ich allein Promo mache, bringt nix.
Die müssen die üblichen Level-Cap-Check-Frags und wir sind nicht alle heißen,
die müssen ein bisschen Werbung machen.
Na nice, für den Sub-Gift.
NS7.
Huge Subscription.
Dankeschön.
Massive.
Big Brain Subs hier.
Ja, der Mesh, der reicht da an, ey.
Die müssten, wir brauchen, die müssten mal, die Typen, die früher auch mit Battlefield groß geworden sind,
die müssten echt mal, also im Prinzip ist es ja nur Check-Frags und Level-Cap.
Äh, ihr Dings, Frankie on PC gibt's ja nimmer.
Die müssten echt mal ein bisschen die Werbetrommel rühren, das wär halt Poggers.
Aber, äh, weiß ich nicht, ob die, ob die, äh, machen.
Zumindest eins muss man sagen, das hier finde ich schon mal richtig nice, auch, auch den, auch den Server-Browser und alles.
Ist schon cool.
Und jetzt läuft's ja auch halbwegs.
Oh!
Alter, Grand Bazaar 126.
Okay, jetzt ist vorbei.
Jetzt ist vorbei.
Das kann ich mir nicht geben.
Oh mein Gott.
Nein, Gott!
Nein, Gott, bitte!
Nein, nein!
Nein!
Nee, das muss nicht sein.
Schluss für heute.
Gibt's ein Level-System?
Nee, nur das, was es sonst in Battlefield auch gibt.
Also Leute, wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut.
Bis dann.
See you.